Someone was screaming inside the incinerator.
The year was 1975.
The location was a top secret refinery and
waste disposal plant, one of the many front
organizations owned and operated by the SCP
Foundation.
This sprawling facility, separated into three
different huge units, each with a specialized
task, was located around 75 kilometers outside
of Summer Springs, Colorado.
It had operated for several decades without
incident, but today, all hell was about to
break loose.
Alarms were blaring in Unit C, the area of
the facility that dealt with
destroying non-anomalous
waste via incineration.
A traumatized worker had pulled the emergency
lever near one of the incinerators in a panic
when he’d first heard the loud banging against
the interior walls, and then, those horrific,
pained wails.
That’s when the workers of Unit C came to
a horrifying realization: The screams weren’t
just coming from one of the incinerators in
Unit C, they were coming from all six.
A chorus of absolute agony, echoing up out
of the ash pits.
This was impossible, as far as the Unit C
staff were concerned.
These incinerators were only to be used for
confirmed non-anomalous material - could some
animals or even some poor workers somehow
fallen into the incinerators?
But even if they had, what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at once?
It was impossible.
The Site Director was immediately brought
in to authorize an investigation, at which
point he demanded that at least one of the
furnaces - in this case, Furnace Number 4
- be shut off so researchers and guards could
investigate what was going on inside.
It seemed like the obvious course of action,
but for some of the people on site that day,
this would prove to be a fatal mistake.
When the fires were put out, something started
rattling in the disposal chute.
There was a scratching and squealing noise,
like something scraping up against the metal.
A maintenance worker was ordered to go check
inside, and when he opened the hatch, he let
out a bone-chilling shriek.
There was something - or was it someone?
- climbing back up the disposal chute.
It emerged from the darkness, backlit by the
still-burning embers of the incinerator, letting
out an awful, screeching noise that could
make even a hardened Mobile Task Force operative
shake with fear.
The creature was humanoid, a charred, mutilated
skeleton, reaching out towards the maintenance
worker with a bony claw.
Before the worker had a chance to stumble
back in horror, the beast had clasped him
by the throat and started to squeeze.
It didn’t even need to strangle him - the
heat of its skeletal hand burned away the
worker’s throat in seconds, leaving his
limp, wheezing body to drop to the metal grate
of the platform below him.
Several armed guards and maintenance workers
moved forward to fend off the monster, but
just then a volley of more violent shrieks
echoed out of the chute behind it.
It only took seconds for over a dozen more
creatures to crawl out of the disposal chute.
They were all like the first - people at various
stages of incineration, some were glowing,
charred skeletons with barely any flesh, others
looking more like severe burn victims, their
faces contorted into scowls of hate and rage.
The assembled guards opened fire on the sudden
influx of anomalies, emptying the magazines
of their submachine guns into the burning
bodies, but their weapons didn’t seem to
cause any lasting damage.
The bullets would tear through the flesh of
the creatures, causing some of them to stumble
and fall, but the wounds would close and the
creatures would rise again.
It seemed they possessed a deadly combo of
extremely high aggression, and incredible
regenerative abilities.
None of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burned corpses attacked anyone they
could find with their bare hands, beating
and biting and clawing.
Many of them would grapple with Foundation
personnel, latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the incinerator
with them.
These creatures that would later be known
as SCP-2419-A caused several fatalities with
their surprise attack that day, and the situation
was only brought back under control when a
Mobile Task Force that possessed more advanced
training and weaponry was dispatched to the
location.
Despite orders from the Site Director, the
MTF found it impossible to actually terminate
any of the entities due to their regenerative
abilities.
Instead, the MTF agents focused on forcing
the anomalies back into the chute of Incinerator
Number 4 using a powerful industrial steam
lance.
Once they were back inside, the incinerator’s
burners were started up once again.
The MTF were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for questioning
and experimentation, finally bringing this
unexpected containment breach to an end.
The Foundation is an organization that prides
itself on possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge, but even they had no idea what
had just happened.
There seemed to be no earthly explanation
why these creatures would suddenly manifest
inside the incinerators, but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating, a slightly
clearer picture of what exactly the Foundation
was dealing with began to emerge.
Every single one of the captured anomalies
kept regenerating, and upon getting to the
point that they were no-longer burn scarred,
the researchers studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical to
a deceased D-Class from the Foundation’s
records.
They were physically and genetically identical
to the dead Class D Personnel.
Perfect copies, save for the fact that their
sole mission in life seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence.
Researchers wanted to gain greater insight
into the minds of these strange creatures
through the use of extensive psychological
evaluations and interviews.
It would turn out to be a
very dangerous investigation.
A psychological researcher by the name of
Dr. Warren conducted an interview with one
of the SCP-2419-A instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset.
This creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began, so it wasn’t
an unreasonable assumption to believe that
it could be capable of speech.
The interviewee was separated from Dr. Warren
by a thick pane of glass to prevent it from
indulging in any of its more violent urges.
The problem was that Dr. Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated what
these creatures were capable of doing to get
what they wanted.
Dr. Warren tried to begin the interview in
good faith.
He spoke calmly and politely to the creature
through the glass, attempting to remind it
of the person it once was.
The anomaly didn’t appear to be paying attention
to the doctor though, instead focusing on
pulling its own arm apart, and breaking the
bones within.
Dr. Warren began to think that the creatures
weren’t even sentient, if the only activity
they seemed to engage in
was the wanton destruction
of themselves and others.
But underestimating them like this proved
to be a big mistake.
By removing the skin off of its arm, and whittling
its bones down to sharp edges, the anomaly
had transformed its arm into a makeshift knife.
Before anyone realized this, it had already
used its own jagged bones to break the glass
divider and attack Dr. Warren.
He perished not long after, after being stabbed
multiple times in his face and eyes and the
anomaly was forcefully taken back to its holding
cell.
Dr. Daniel Jennings, a senior researcher,
was then put on the case.
He released a chilling memo on the creatures
after his observation period ended.
It read:
“Before I came here, I worked as a prison
shrink.
Every person you met had a story bursting
with pain and sorrow.
Sometimes, those stories were about the pain
they suffered; sometimes, it was about the
pain they inflicted.
Some days you felt like everyone there was
a beautiful soul torn down by their circumstances
— other days, you'd find out what some of
them did and a part of you was glad they were
there to suffer for it.
But at the end of every day, I always told
myself: They're all humans.
They're all people.
They all deserve the same dignity, respect,
and love as everyone else.
No exceptions.”
Dr. Jennings goes on.
“I opened up with that anecdote only so
you could understand that what I'm about to
say is not said lightly: These things are
not people.
They are people-shaped monsters.
They are well beyond any
definition of psychopathy.
Everything they do, they do to hurt, maim,
and kill.
I would pity them, but that would imply that
they're worth pitying.
Put them in a hole, then fill that hole with
concrete.
Better still: Throw them back into the incinerator
where you found them.
I doubt they'll even care.”
Following this string of unfortunate incidents,
containment procedures were put into place
to hopefully prevent anything that had happened
to the unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again.
The entire facility was fenced off, and was
constantly patrolled by MTF Beta-7, also known
as the Maz Hatters, a group specializing in
containing anomalies which present powerful
biological, chemical, or radiological dangers.
The furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerged from remain lit at all times, with
workers checking and carrying out maintenance
on every single one, each day of the week.
Outside of this, the facility is essentially
a no-go zone.
Reinforced steel hatches cover the chutes,
and they are to forever remain bolted shut.
All because of that one terrifying day in
1975.
That was the day that the Summer Springs waste
disposal facility, which had been a valuable
asset to the Foundation for decades, instead
became classified as the Euclid-Class anomaly
SCP-2419.
It’s not uncommon for a Foundation asset
to one day become a dangerous anomaly requiring
containment, but the same question always
pops up after...
Why?
Why had a place that had been so valuable
to the Foundation suddenly become such an
active danger?
The answer, as is often the case, is contained
within the question.
Why would a waste disposal plant be so important
to the Foundation in the first place?
And more importantly, what else was going
on at the plant to make it such an area of
active importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world?
To put it simply, the plant allowed the Foundation
to dispose of something far more important
than mere waste material - it gave them what
they needed to better erase memories.
As you probably already know, the Foundation
makes liberal use of amnestics on those exposed
to anomalous material to make them forget
what they have seen and experienced, but these
elusive chemicals - many of which are sourced
from SCP-3000 - are an inexact science.
However, at the Summer Springs waste disposal
plant, researchers discovered an immensely
valuable alternative.
Much of what was disposed of in the incinerators
of Unit C were the bodies of dead D-Class
personnel.
Before being burned, autopsies were performed
on the bodies to make sure they were non-anomalous
- including the brain.
Back in the 1960s, while performing research
on the brains of the dead D-Classes, they
found a method of extracting and distilling
the positive memories of the dead, creating
a kind of “Happy Soup.”
When administered into someone who has undergone
amnestic treatment, this happy soup creates
positive false memories in their mind that
fills in those pesky blank spaces that are
often behind.
This was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single D-Class
corpse that passed through Unit C, totaling
well into the thousands by the time that the
first SCP-2419-A instances began to rise.
But as all happiness, joy, and love were removed
from the minds of the D-Classes, it seemed
that all that was left was pure hate, pain,
violence, and fury.
Feelings too intense and evil to destroy.
These were bodies imbued with a malice so
powerful that no fire could ever burn them
away.
They exist now with single-minded determination
to get out and destroy everything around them.
Everything.
Including the ones that made them, the SCP
Foundation itself.
And in the end, it’s only a matter of time
until they get out.
There are thousands of them in there, unable
to die, unable to stop.
The only thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around them,
and those furnaces can’t burn forever.
The monsters lurking in SCP-2419 will outlive
the fire that surrounds them, because while
the furnaces they are contained in are hot,
the fires of hate that burn within SCP2419
entities are even more powerful.
And they know this.
They know they can’t be contained forever,
and that someday soon, they’ll be able to
emerge and exact their terrible revenge.
Those who must walk past the incinerators
may think they hear their screams echoing
out from within, but it’s not screaming
at all.
It’s laughter.
It’s a natural instinct in many species
to protect their young - and sometimes it's
not just their own babies, but any young that
look like them.
Regardless of your personal feelings on human’s
earliest stage, it is a scientific fact that
human babies are designed to emphasize their
own adorable helplessness to make sure that
other, older humans take care of them.
A baby’s cry is an inherently distressing
sound, and when we hear it, some deep, primal
part of us feels the urge to comfort and care
for the child until the sound stops.
But of course, we’re talking about the world
of the SCP Foundation here - where there are
bunnies that can eat anything, teddy bears
that might steal your organs to make duplicates
of themselves, and chocolate fountains filled
with trillions of murderous insects.
Nothing is what it seems here, and even the
most innocent and cute creatures may be hiding
a deadly secret - SCP-734 being no exception.
Today, we’re talking about The Baby.
This anomaly proves that dangerous things
can come in small packages, but where others
only saw misery and death, the SCP Foundation
saw a certain potential…
Our story begins in the maternity ward of
a hospital in the USA, where every medical
professional’s worst nightmare was unfolding:
An unknown but incredibly fast-acting flesh-eating
pathogen seemed to be running rampant across
the hospital’s population.
It began when patients who weren’t even
admitted for dermatological issues started
complaining of severe itches and extreme skin
pain.
Some nurses and doctors in the maternity ward
began to experience similar symptoms, as well
as one of the infants, leading to a massive
quarantine effort.
While the initial symptoms first appeared
to be limited to severe pain and discomfort
on isolated parts of the skin, the condition
of the afflicted soon escalated.
Their skin began to messily flake off as the
cells comprising it lost physical cohesion
and died.
It was a kind of strange, anomalous rot that
seemed to work inwards, first destroying the
integrity of the outer layer of skin and then
causing further disintegration to deeper parts
of the body.
Once the skin had shed off, the pathogen would
turn its attention to what was lying beneath.
Against all odds, the disease affected organs,
muscle tissue, the vascular system, and even
bones.
Nothing was spared.
The victims’ bodies would completely break
down, and they would be dead within a few
hours.
By the time the pathogen had finished ravaging
its victims, what was left didn’t even look
human anymore.
Not only patients but doctors and nurses that
had been walking the wards mere hours before
were now little more than piles of human tissue
sitting in what had previously been their
hospital beds.
Whatever this was, it seemed like the fastest
progressing infection in recorded history.
Hospital staff and administrators were terrified
- this appeared to be an entirely new disease,
with a mysterious form of transmission and,
worst of all, no cure.
They were even more confused when several
black vans pulled up outside the hospital,
and mysterious men in hazmat suits spilled
out and began setting up a quarantine zone
around the entire building.
Whoever these strange people were, they definitely
weren’t the CDC - little did the hospital
personnel know that this was the group you
never want showing up and putting your location
on lockdown - it was the SCP Foundation.
The infected remains of the victims were taken
away for research purposes, and the Foundation
operatives immediately began conducting debriefing
interviews with witnesses.
They soon determined from a mix of eyewitness
accounts and hospital surveillance footage
that everyone infected with the mysterious
pathogen had all been in a particular section
of the maternity ward earlier in the day.
And when the operatives investigated this
area, they found another strange detail.
An infant had no registered mother present
in the hospital.
The Foundation would later learn that this
was likely because the baby’s mother was
the first victim of the deadly disease.
After eliminating all other possible options,
it seemed that the only anomalous element
that could have caused all of this was the
mysterious baby, though just how the mother
even survived carrying the baby to term was
a mystery in and of itself.
The baby was a caucasian male human infant
between seven and eight months of age.
Nothing appeared outwardly anomalous about
the child, but they could confirm that every
single victim of the anomalous pathogen had
come into physical contact with the child
earlier that day.
Everyone who had been at the hospital was
given amnestic treatment, and the Foundation
constructed plausible cover stories for the
deaths that had occurred that day.
Like so many others before it, the child was
secured and spirited away
to the nearest applicable
Foundation containment site.
There it was reclassified as SCP-734, and
finally the real testing into what precisely
this infant was capable of could begin.
Physiologically, SCP-734
appeared mostly non-anomalous.
The infant had above-average intelligence
and physical aptitude for a child his age
but otherwise showed no mutations or abnormalities
that would suggest a divergence from typical
human biology.
Despite a vast array of tests performed by
the Foundation into essentially every aspect
of 734’s biology, they couldn’t find anything
that hinted at the origin of the mysterious
pathogen.
But through some trial and extremely costly
error, the Foundation was able to learn more
about how exactly the pathogen worked.
The only vector for transmission seemed to
be direct contact with the baby itself, up
to and including the fluids and residues it
leaves behind.
Those affected cannot transmit the anomalous
“flaking” effect to others, meaning that
the risk of an epidemic is relievingly minimal.
But of course, accidents still happen, as
was discovered when one agent misplaced her
sympathy for the baby and decided to remove
her mask while interacting with him.
Her logic was that her masked face might have
caused the baby some kind of distress, and
as long as she was only coming into contact
with him via her own gloved hands, everything
would be fine.
But some dust particles were floating in the
air at the time, and SCP-734 sneezed in her
face.
The agent began screaming in pain and recoiling
from the baby, but it was already too late.
Her fate was sealed.
She was taken to the infirmary and given sedatives
so that she could hopefully die in as little
pain as possible.
In roughly 72% of cases, amputation of the
affected areas has prevented the entire body
from succumbing to the anomalous effects of
SCP-734, but this isn’t exactly feasible
when the point of contact is the victim’s
head.
Within hours, the agent’s flesh had flaked
off of her face, leaving her looking like
a red, bloody skull.
A few hours after that, she didn’t have
a head at all.
Throughout the disintegration process of this
unfortunate agent, the Foundation took grisly
photographs.
These photographs are shown to anyone preparing
to work on the SCP-734 research project to
teach them a hard lesson on the importance
of adhering to proper safety protocols.
And these protocols about how to deal with
the Baby are incredibly tight, given that
even incidental contact is often a death sentence.
Anyone entering the Baby’s containment chamber
needs to wear contained-atmosphere hazmat
suits.
Anyone who makes physical contact with the
Baby, even when suited up, is immediately
removed from the area and subject to several
hours of quarantine and observation.
Even inanimate objects that have been inside
the containment chamber need to be thoroughly
sterilized before being removed.
Given that even anomalous children like SCP-734
have very delicate needs, a handler is always
standing by in full hazmat gear to take care
of the baby.
These handlers are rotated every hour to maintain
alertness and safety.
These handlers feed and change SCP-734 regularly
and sometimes even provide toys that have
been approved by the O5 Council.
The Foundation has gone to great lengths to
keep SCP-734 alive and comfortable because
they believe that SCP-734 could be an important
asset for them in the future.
Or, more specifically, they see great strategic
value in SCP-734’s blood.
As mentioned earlier, contact with any matter
from SCP-734 triggers its deadly anomalous
effects, including bodily fluids like blood.
But, unlike many toxic pathogens, in this
case there is no risk of the infection getting
out of control since the infected do not become
vectors for transmission.
Because of this, the blood of SCP-734 can
act as a powerful weapon for both terminating
anomalies deemed unviable by the O5 Council
and assassinating dangerous people who belong
to rival groups.
Contact with the blood would completely destroy
the target’s body, with no other anomalous
effects and no evidence of who exactly conducted
the hit.
SCP-734 has been fitted with an arterial catheter
so that the Foundation can
collect large quantities
of blood from the anomalous infant every single
week for storage and research.
But it isn’t just the blood that the Foundation
sees potential in.
SCP-734 himself has scored incredibly well
on the Aeslinger Loyalty Index, the test the
Foundation uses to judge the loyalty of potential
applicants to the Foundation cause.
As SCP-734 matures, if these scores remain
consistent, he will likely be trained to become
a Foundation field agent in the future.
An agent capable of killing someone with a
touch would, needless to say, be an asset
to certain covert missions that the Foundation
would probably prefer to keep off the books.
Of course, the SCP Foundation recruiting certain
compliant anomalies to perform missions for
them is far from unprecedented.
The most infamous of these is SCP-076, also
known as Able, a supernatural,
eternally-resurrecting
swordsman and perhaps one of the finest warriors
who ever lived.
The Foundation took note of this and channeled
his eternal thirst for battle into working
with his very own Mobile Task Force.
He could assist in missions by taking out
his bloodlust on enemy groups of interest
and dangerous anomalies.
However, this ended up working a little too
well and led to disaster.
Able was so good at his job that he burned
through all his allotted missions at astonishing
speed.
Left with nothing more to do, Able got antsy,
which led to him turning his murderous desires
on his fellow team members and then the Foundation
as a whole.
It was an all-out massacre before his colleagues
were finally able to kill him and return him
to containment.
The failure of this initiative gave the very
idea of letting anomalies work for the Foundation
in the field a bad name.
But since then, things have changed, especially
with the establishment of MTF Alpha-9, aka
Last Hope, a new mobile task force formed
entirely of anomalous individuals and their
handlers.
These consist of somewhat more stable anomalies,
such as Able’s counterpart, SCP-073, also
known as Cain.
Cain cannot be harmed, with any harm befalling
him simply being mirrored back on his attacker,
and his vast array of knowledge makes him
an incredibly useful intelligence asset.
Another of the several members of Last Hope
is Iris, also known as SCP-105.
Much like Cain, Iris not only has anomalous
powers that make her immensely valuable for
missions in the field, she’s also compliant
and capable of listening to reason, unlike
Cain.
Her abilities include being able to actively
surveil and even interact with photos of any
location, especially when taken with her anomalous
camera.
Someday, SCP-734 could count himself among
other anomalous Foundation agents like these,
providing he continues to show promise and
doesn’t develop a dislike of the Foundation
as he ages, since after all, he won’t be
a baby forever.
So if ever you find yourself on the Foundation’s
bad side, you have a good reason to be paranoid.
You’ll have no idea that one day, the man
who’s going to kill you will approach and
shake your hand with a smile.
It won’t be until later when you feel that
strange tingle on your palm and feel the skin
starting to flake away that you’ll realize
you’ve been a dead man walking for hours.
Endless.
That’s a word you’re likely to hear thrown
around a lot at the SCP Foundation.
Like SCP-3008, known as the Infinite Ikea.
Endless.
Or take the life of the tragically immortal
Dr. Bright, who became one with the SCP-963,
and now is condemned to existing within it
on some level forever.
Endless.
Or most pertinent of all for today’s video,
take SCP-087, a terrifying staircase full
of tangible darkness and a frightening and
unknowable entity.
No matter how far down you go, it seems as
though there’s just another flight, waiting
for you.
Endless.
But really, is anything ever really endless?
Or is endless just the word we use for something
when we haven’t found that sought-after
end just yet?
For those who travel far enough, there may
be a limit to the infinite Ikea.
Someday, Dr. Bright’s medallion one day
might lay inert and lifeless, with no traces
of his consciousness left.
And for those who venture down far enough,
able to clench their teeth and get past the
fear, you may someday find that even SCP-087
has a final flight.
But what if this isn’t just a hypothetical.
What if this has already happened, but the
truth was considered too dangerous or too
horrifying to share?
What’s really at the bottom of SCP-087?
Today, we hope to find out.
Let’s just also hope that knowing doesn’t
end up being more of a burden than we’d
expected…
Before we head to the bottom of the Endless
Staircase though, we must first return to
SCP-087’s file and refresh our memories
on some of the crucial basics.
After all, it’s been quite some time since
our last video on the subject.
This Euclid-Class anomaly is one of the most
well-known and feared, partially thanks to
classified information being leaked via a
certain video game, probably coded by the
Serpent’s Hand.
As we alluded to earlier, many know 087 as
the Endless Staircase, based in an administrative
building of a classified North American university
campus.
It’s been behind a number of mysterious
deaths and disappearances and has left many
of its escaping victims traumatized and in
a state of permanent catatonia.
Having to descend the staircase is just that
terrifying.
Equally infamous as the staircase itself are
the three tests that the Foundation conducted
into the staircase before deciding to just
board up the door forever.
In the first, a D-Class that was once a member
of the Foundation was forced to see just how
many flights he could descend.
Not long after first entering the staircase
and beginning to make his way down, he heard
the desperate and distressed pleas of a child.
He kept descending but found he seemed to
be getting no closer to the source of the
distress.
When he was deep enough, that’s when he
encountered SCP-087-1, a frightening, uncanny
face with few discernible features.
The sheer terror of encountering this entity
was enough to send him running back to the
top.
The second test played out similarly, with
a D-Class being sent in with a number of powerful,
sticky-backed lights that he was ordered to
place against the walls as he descended.
This was done in hopes of increasing visibility
on the staircase.
However, it proved to be unsuccessful, as
the darkness in 087 is more of a tangible
presence than the mere absence of light.
It was able to smother out visibility regardless
of a light source’s power.
Once again, the D-Class heard the crying,
and encountered the face, causing him to flee.
And the third and penultimate test involved
a D-Class who got really unlucky.
She traversed the staircase deeper than any
of her predecessors, before
eventually encountering
the horrifying face of SCP-087-1.
However, rather than running up and away from
the entity, in a state of sheer panic, the
D-Class instead ran downwards, deeper and
deeper into the staircase.
The audio cut as the face continued in its
pursuit, and the D-Class was never seen again.
Did you notice that we said “penultimate”
and not “final” before that last one?
That’s because there’s actually a highly
classified fourth expedition into the SCP-087
Staircase, but as you can see on the original
file, the data is expunged.
What could have happened in that study that
led the Foundation to wipe it from the records?
Did they discover the great secret behind
SCP-087, a secret too horrible for mortal
minds to bear?
We’re not just going to give you one answer
today, we’re going to give you three.
That’s right: Three different interpretations
of the secret fourth expedition into SCP-087.
Which is the real one?
Well you’ll just have to see.
After all, nothing is simple when it comes
to SCP-087.
Though our first potential option is the most
simple of the three.
In this iteration of the experiment, a male
D-Class murderer was instructed to descend
the staircase into the heart of SCP-087, with
the Foundation hoping to find out what happened
to D-9884, the female D-Class who’d disappeared
at the conclusion of the third expedition.
In a sense, this new D-Class would discover
the fate that most likely befell D-9884, but
through first-hand experience rather than
distant observation.
Being directed by Dr. Airdo over walkie-talkie,
the male D-Class slowly got deeper into the
anomaly, flight by flight.
Predictably, he began to hear the intensely
distressed crying of a small child around
200 meters below him and immediately felt
a sense of paranoia and dread wash over his
mind.
Despite this, Dr. Airdo ordered him to keep
going, descending deeper and deeper into the
bowels of SCP-087.
Over time, the sheer psychological exhaustion
of SCP-087 was beginning to take its toll
on the D-Class, leading to him taking a brief
break in order to nap.
However, he awoke with a violent start, seeing
the horrific face of SCP-087-1 staring down
at him.
It felt like all his worst nightmares had
come to life.
In order to escape the monster, he began to
flee further down into SCP-087, much like
D-9884 before him.
It would be the last mistake he ever made.
When he finally reached the very bottom of
the 087 staircases, the D-Class realized he
was trapped.
Nowhere to run, nowhere to hide.
Suddenly, the face of SCP-087-1 was hovering
over him again, boring its gaze into him.
As the D-Class directed his powerful flashlight
at the creature, he saw that this time, it
was more than just a face.
The entity had a whole body, seven or eight
feet long, with that same ghostly white and
deathlike appearance.
It reached out with huge, clawed hands and
grasped the D-Class.
Before the audio and video feed cut out entirely,
the last thing the attending researchers heard
was screaming from the hapless D-Class, and
the crunch of his bones within the creature’s
huge hands.
But of course, that’s just one of three
possible insane discoveries at the very bottom
of SCP-087.
Let’s turn our attention to the next one,
and see if its answer to the SCP-087 riddle
seems to satisfy all of our burning questions.
Much like the previous iteration, a single
male D-Class was sent into the clutches of
SCP-087 in hopes of getting some answers on
what happened to D-9884.
Of course, he was given all the standard equipment
- from a 75-watt flashlight to a defensive
weapon to a healthy supply of water and nutrition
bars.
None of which would save him in the end.
Like all the others, this D-Class descended
those accursed stairs, getting deeper and
deeper.
When he reached a certain point on the way
down, he heard something, but not the crying
of a child like all the others had reported.
It was an adult woman’s scream.
Specifically, it was the scream of D-9884,
exactly as the Foundation researchers had
heard it over the audio feed in her last moments
before disappearing.
This was progress.
The researchers instructed this male D-Class
to go deeper, passing flight after flight,
until finally the SCP-087-1 face appeared.
But again, something was different, something
was wrong.
Now, it looked more like the face of D-9884,
just without her mouth and pupils.
Had SCP-087-1 been stealing the faces of its
prior victims?
Had the previous face been stolen from a student
who’d gone missing from the campus?
These were all questions the male D-Class
didn’t have time to ponder, as he was too
busy running for dear life.
But he didn’t get far.
Despite having no history of such medical
problems, the male D-Class suddenly experienced
a seizure while attempting to escape, and
collapsed.
The last thing his video feed picked up before
losing transmission was a pair of long, white
arms emerging from the dark, crushing him
inside of its huge hands, before dragging
his enfolded corpse into the darkness.
That’s another chilling potential account
of the possible fourth expedition into SCP-087,
but we can’t stop now.
We still have one more tale of terror to share
before this video is done.
In the next and final iteration, two D-Classes
- one male and one female - were sent down
together in hopes of discovering what had
happened to D-9884.
And by the end, they would have their answer,
but they certainly wouldn’t like it.
As the two of them descended, they saw the
marks on the wall where the adhesive lights
from expedition two had been somehow torn
off.
But the deeper they descended, the more disturbing
the things they found became.
They discovered words clawed into the stone
walls, each one revealing a piece of a more
frightening puzzle the deeper down SCP-087
they traversed.
They descended further, sustaining minor injuries
from a foul-smelling and caustic substance
left on some of the walls and floors around
them.
At some point along the journey, a light was
dropped, and in the brief seconds of darkness,
the female D-Class disappeared.
The male D-Class was ordered to go deeper
and deeper into the staircase until he finally
began to hear the crying of a little girl.
When he reached the 666th floor, he found
a wooden door, with the word “HOME” scratched
into it.
He steeled himself and entered the room.
But it wasn’t a room at all, it was a field,
shrouded in darkness with a distant tree.
A little girl - the one who had been crying
- was finally, actually here.
She told the D-Class that she’d always been
here, and her father had been trying to find
her a body so she could go “upstairs”,
but for that to happen, she’d have to be
properly birthed first.
That’s when the male D-Class noticed the
two huge stone slabs just beyond the darkness:
On one was the corpse of D-9884, hanged by
her wrists with thick, metal chains.
Her abdomen had been fully cut open, as though
a brutal c-section had been performed on her.
And on the other stone was the female D-Class
who’d been accompanying him this whole time,
strung up but still very much alive - seemingly
the next potential vessel for the little girl’s
rebirth.
But this didn’t mean that the male D-Class
would be left out of the fun, either.
After all, the little girl’s father would
need a new body, too, if he wanted to accompany
his daughter upstairs.
The father in question being SCP-087-1, which
appeared in the room moments later and swooped
in towards the male D-Class.
What followed was a battery of nightmarish
sounds as the darkness expanded and consumed
the field once more.
Not long after this, the Foundation sealed
off the entrance to SCP-087 forever, now knowing
that it potentially contained multiple hostile
entities intent on escaping into our world
and causing further damage.
Students in the area reported a number of
frantic knocks coming from the door for a
brief period after that until the Foundation
finally had it properly soundproofed, and
the issues were seemingly over with.
For now.
Everyone loves a good ghost story.
Whether you’re crowded around a campfire
or watching a YouTube video at 3 AM, there’s
something fun and exciting about imagining
haunted places plagued by strange noises and
apparitions.
Part of what makes it so fun is the idea that
any place can be haunted, especially if terrible
things have happened there.
That decrepit old house at the end of your
street, that 80 year old movie theater where
no one goes anymore, a park where one too
many kids went missing.
All it takes is a tragic backstory and a creepy
atmosphere, and it’s easy to believe that
any place could be teeming with restless spirits.
So, it stands to reason that a place with
as many unsolved deaths as the SCP Foundation
might have a ghost or two lurking in the shadows.
If you’ve ever suspected that the SCP foundation
might be haunted, well…you’d be right.
It began, as all good ghost stories do, with
a series of frightening, unexplained events.
Some time ago, personnel at SCP Foundation
Site-30 began to notice strange things happening
around the facility.
Obviously, at a place like an SCP Foundation
Containment Site, strange is relative, but
these events seemed to have nothing to do
with any of the entities contained at the
site.
There were unexplained sounds reported in
the private quarters of agents and researchers,
ranging from whispers to screams from an unseen
being.
Personnel who approached the D-Class block
at the site noticed an
immediate drop in temperature,
with some employees even claiming that they
could see their own breath.
Several personnel reported items going missing
while they were alone in a room.
Most were small and easily misplaced objects
like pens and clipboards, but one man said
his wallet disappeared, which wouldn’t be
that strange if it hadn’t been securely
inside his lab coat.
Other personnel would be innocently washing
their hands, only to be
horrified by the appearance
of a bloody figure in a D-Class jumpsuit in
the mirror, staring back at them with hatred
in its eyes.
There were anomalous computer server errors,
the feeling of being watched or followed by
some menacing invisible force, even the sight
of a shadowy silhouette fleeing down corridors
and hiding around corners.
All of these occurrences were reported to
higher-ups at the Foundation, but they were
all dismissed.
The Directorial Board of the site insisted
that these accounts were likely the result
of employees cracking under the mental stress
of working under such strenuous circumstances.
If left alone, they were certain that the
reports would stop.
But the reports didn’t stop, and they soon
found out that this was only the beginning.
There was an uptick in containment breaches
following these initial reports.
In total, twelve different entities were released
from their containment, and the origin of
these breaches could not be identified.
Thankfully, the entities were captured and
returned to their containment facilities before
any casualties could result.
But from there things kept getting worse.
Over the course of several months, there were
six different employee suicides on site.
Security footage of the deceased operatives
shortly before their deaths showed them acting
deeply troubled, engaging in agitated conversation
with someone not visible to the camera.
At first, it was posited that whoever was
upsetting the employees was in a blind spot,
but it quickly became clear that the dead
employees were being tormented by something
invisible.
Stories of hauntings were one thing, but now
with escaped SCPs and a notable death count,
the Directorial Board decided to mount an
official investigation into the unexplained
occurrences.
It was then that the spirit was officially
acknowledged, identified, and re-classified
as SCP-4973.
SCP-4973 was once a D-Class worker who was
used as a guinea pig in 25 different experiments
with a variety of entities on site.
He was repeatedly exposed to multiple unusual
and dangerous anomalies, including SCP-158,
a large mechanical arm capable of extracting
an unidentified substance from any living
test subject.
Before he was brought on board at SCP Foundation
Site-30, he was known as Gordon Kardivachlus
Markovitch, a man who had been convicted of
Murder in the Second Degree after stabbing
his wife 24 times in the chest with a kitchen
knife.
During his incarceration,
Markovitch was transferred
to the custody of the SCP Foundation and placed
at Site-30 where he was given a new name,
D-10000.
During an experiment involving a redacted
entity, D-10000 was killed and his remains
were disposed of at a nearby waste refinery.
It was then only three months after his death,
that the initial reports of ghost activity
began.
SCP-4973 is regarded as a Class IV Spectral
Entity, meaning that it is an entity displaying
a high degree of aggression and malevolence
toward a specific individual or group.
In this case, the spirit displays hostility
towards a very specific
group - the SCP Foundation.
Class IV entities can affect the environment
around them, move objects, reduce the temperature
in a room, and induce hallucinations in humans
that it comes into contact with.
These hallucinations are thought to be the
cause of the increase in employee suicides
that occurred after 4973’s first appearance.
One of the many ways in which SCP-4973 acted
out, in what is believed to be an attempt
at revenge on the Foundation as a whole, was
to somehow gain access to the SCiPNET Database
Terminal.
This allowed the spirit to learn about the
entities contained at the site, as well as
personal details regarding the lives of research,
security, and administrative staff working
there.
This information is likely what allowed 4973
to cause several suspected containment breaches,
though the specifics of those breaches have
been expunged from official records.
4973 was eventually contained within an apparatus
known as an Incorporeal Entity Vacuum Chamber,
which is consistently monitored by a team
of specialists within MTF Mu-13, affectionately
nicknamed “Ghostbusters.”
In order to prevent it from escaping, four
Harrington-Hollow Neutralizer Wards have been
placed at the door to the containment facility.
This containment method
has been largely effective,
though the spirit has escaped a handful of
times and had to be recaptured and placed
back into the IEVC.
In order to understand SCP-4973, and uncover
how it was able to access the database, Dr.
Lorraine Casper was assigned to conduct an
interview with the spirit, speaking to it
as it was in containment, and a transcript
of this interview is available in the official
Foundation archives.
Dr. Casper began the conversation politely,
addressing the SCP as Gordon and asking him
how he was.
Gordon refused to comply with the round of
questioning, going as far as to yell at Dr.
Casper until she reminded him that he faced
the risk of termination if he refused to answer
her questions.
Dr. Casper pointed out that the files accessed
by 4973 required clearance that the spirit
would have no way of possessing.
He responded that he simply waved his hand
across the terminal in order to access it,
explaining: “It freaked out for a second
and then it just - stopped...
I could just move my fingers around the air
and the tabs would just roll up.
Easy as that.”
Dr. Casper asked for clarification, inquiring
how he could even do something like that.
4973 continued his explanation, “Beats me.
It felt like some attraction.
Like magnets from afar getting closer and
closer.
I dunno, something like that.”
Finding this answer unsatisfactory, Dr. Casper
pushed further, asking for an explanation
of SCP-4973’s attempts to release dangerous
onsite anomalies from containment.
This question seemed to stump him, and he
claimed not to understand what Dr. Casper
meant.
She explained that the ID cards of Dr. Yurkov
and Dr. Orson were used to open the facilities
from which these anomalies escaped.
4973 was shocked that he had been suspected
of this attack, and insisted not to know who
Orson or Yurkov even were.
All of a sudden, he trailed off.
There was silence for a moment, and Dr. Casper
began to collect her notes and leave, assuming
that the interview was over.
Much to her surprise, SCP-4973 began to laugh,
a loud uproarious laugh of complete and utter
delight.
Casper asked what 4973 was laughing about,
and was met with the response: “God, this
whole time, you and your ghost-hunting crew
never knew?”
He refused to clarify what it was exactly
the doctor and her crew had missed, only saying
“God, that look on your face when you find
out it’s been right under your noses this
whole time.”
He continued to laugh at Dr. Casper for the
remainder of the interview, refusing to answer
any further questions or explain any of his
comments.
Finally, Dr. Casper grew exasperated and left,
ending the interview for real this time.
Following this perplexing interview, Dr. Casper
inexplicably abandoned her post at Site-30.
Her supervisors could not reach her, neither
could any of the other researchers at the
site.
No one heard from her for an entire week,
until one day she called Director Eric Riverson
of Site-30 on his personal phone line.
He recorded the conversation, and a transcript
has been included in the file for SCP-4973.
Dr. Casper explained to Director Riverson
that she had been hiding in her private residence
away from the site, and that she no longer
considered any part of the site safe.
In fact, she suggested that all SCP Foundation
sites might be potentially compromised.
She explained her conversation with SCP-4973,
and the questions it provoked her to ask.
If he had not been behind the containment
breaches, then who was?
He never encountered Dr. Yurkov or Orson in
any of the tests administered on him, and
Orson wasn’t even employed at the Foundation
until after 4973’s death.
Dr. Casper posited that, though the spirit
of Gordon was not responsible for the breaches,
another spectral force, or forces, at the
site might be.
Her hypothesis?
That Site-30 was positively infested with
the vengeful spirits of Class D employees
lost over the years during various experiments.
In order to prove her theory, Dr. Casper got
her hands on all of the experimental equipment
used by the department researching spectral
anomalies.
The general consensus among researchers in
this field is that spirits leak out a kind
of energy, known as ectoplasm, wherever they
go.
It has been compared to the skin left behind
when a spider or a snake molts, a nonessential
portion of the entity that is shed and leaves
a residue in areas where they have been.
Unsurprisingly, a huge amount of ectoplasm
was detected inside of Site-30.
The spirits went undetected at first, as many
of them were dormant for quite some time.
Dormant spirits are spirits that are not aware
of their surroundings or the circumstances
of their deaths, and they do not emit large
quantities of ectoplasm.
It is likely that, after Gordon was trapped,
several of the dormant spirits of Site-30
began to remember what was done to them, and
manifest in more aggressive ways.
Because Gordon was presumed to be the only
spirit at the site, their gradual appearance
and acting out was either ignored, or presumed
to be Gordon escaping from containment.
After her realization, Dr. Casper identified
an additional five active spirits at the site,
and was able to capture and contain one of
them.
Dr. Casper warned Director Riverson that there
were likely far more spirits than just those
five, and it was only a matter of time before
they woke up and became active like the others.
The large amount of previous containment breaches
attributed to simple “human error” becomes
deeply sinister once it is clear that there
have been vengeful spirits hiding in plain
sight the entire time.
As Gordon put it in his interview, they were
just under their noses the whole time.
Dr. Casper’s findings, and the story of
Site-30, present a troubling possibility.
Every SCP Foundation site has used massive
amounts of Class D Personnel in human experiments
with dangerous entities, and the body count
at nearly all of them is staggering.
If Dr. Casper is right, then every single
site has the makings of a haunted house.
All of them could be infested with the spirits
of dead angry D-Class, who are just waiting
to wake up and take their revenge on the still
living members of the organization that killed
them.
And it’s only a matter of time before they
get the chance.
I used to complain about work all the time.
The long hours, the disrespect from my boss,
getting home exhausted, aching, and sunburned. I
worked in construction a lifetime ago. I’d give
anything to go back to that now. What’s that they
always say? You don’t know what you’ve got until
it’s gone? Maybe I deserve the hand I’ve been
dealt. I haven’t been a good person. I don’t play
well with others. There was an argument with my
foreman, one that got a little too heated, and I
just couldn’t reign in my temper.
The hammer I’d been using all day
was still in my hand…but I digress.
I used to build things with my hands,
but I’m in a different line of work now. If you
can call it work. That would imply I get paid,
I clock in every morning, and I get to go
home afterward. I don’t. I’m a prisoner,
really. A glorified lab rat, and property of
the all-powerful SCP Foundation. I’ve been
here about three weeks, and everyone always says
D-Classes like us last about a month here. So,
the clock is ticking down to zero for me. I
haven’t had to do anything too dangerous yet,
but like I said. It’s just a matter of time.
I’m sitting in my cell, the same windowless box
I’ve spent every day for the past three weeks,
when a guard bursts in and grabs me by the arm.
“What’s going on?” I ask, but he ignores me.
Of course, why make conversation with a lab rat?
Better not to think of us as human at all.
He yanks me down the hall, opens a door,
and shoves me inside. There are several other
D-Class in there already, and they’re staring
at something in the corner that I can’t
quite make out. I start to turn around,
to take in the rest of the room, but a voice
comes over the loudspeaker, cold and clinical.
“Look at the statue in the corner.
Do not take your eyes off it.”
Well, when a disembodied voice at the SCP
Foundation tells you to look at something,
you’d better do it. So, I look.
It's a sculpture, made from concrete and
rebar. It looks pretty harmless, but I’ve heard
enough screams through the walls to know that they
don’t keep too many harmless things caged
up here. Whatever this thing really is,
I don’t want to know what it’ll do to me when
my back is turned. I stare at it, unblinking,
feeling my eyes burn and tear up from the
dry air and concentration. I’m scared to
close my eyes for even a second, determined
not to be the first one in here to break.
But something out there has other plans for
me, for us. I hear a warbling sound like a
motor struggling to start, the sudden crash of
thunder outside, and then…the room goes black.
For a second I think I’ve gone blind, but
then I hear the other guys screaming, the
yelling of scientists behind the wall. Somehow,
the power’s gone out. I can’t see anything,
but I can hear the sound of stone scraping
against itself, the snap of breaking bones,
the thud of a limp body slumping to the floor.
The room comes into focus again, as a backup
generator kicks in and fills the space with weak
fluorescent light. But something’s different,
something’s wrong. The statue in the corner
is gone. The other two men are on the floor,
heads twisted around backwards.
And the door is standing wide open.
Is this a trap? A trick of some kind? If I
run out that door, will a guard be waiting
there for me? I don’t know, but whatever might
happen to me if I try can’t be any worse than
what will happen if I stay right here.
Through the wall, I hear that sickening
snapping sound again, a corpse thudding to the
ground. They didn’t plan this. Something in
their experiment went horribly wrong, for them.
And maybe, just maybe, it went right for me.
I don’t give it a second thought, I’m out the
door, running through the dimly lit halls,
through the maze of identical corridors
in search of some kind of exit.
All around me, there’s chaos. Guards firing
their weapons at inhuman shapes that I catch
a brief glimpse of as I run past, scientists
yelling for help, people going as fast as they
can toward the danger and away from it.
I’m so caught up in it all, I don’t even
notice when I run right into a woman in
a white lab coat, knocking us both to the
ground. I scramble to my feet, and look at her
with wide eyes, waiting for her to turn me in,
to call the guards. But she doesn’t.
“I’m so sorry,” I stammer.
She holds out a hand, gesturing for me to help
her to her feet. So, I do. “Watch your step,
there,” she says, with a knowing smile. I
can’t help but notice how beautiful she is,
twinkling brown eyes and thick black hair.
Then, I spot them, tucked under her hair but
unmistakable. She has a pair of fox ears on top
of her head. It hits me in rapid succession then,
all the things about this woman that don’t look
quite right. Her unusually long nails, too sharp
and pointed for lab work. The feral glint in
her eyes. The halting cadence of her voice.
This woman is not an employee of the
SCP Foundation. She’s doing the same
thing I am: taking advantage of
the situation to try and escape.
"I'll be more careful from now on,
ma’am,” I say. She winks and turns
down the hall. I can see a tail poking
out beneath the bottom of her lab coat.
“Safe travels!” I call after her. She laughs, a
dangerous sound, like she’s not the one who needs
to worry about staying safe, and I wonder what
might have happened if I had caught her in a worse
mood. Good thing my mom taught me my manners.
Now, which way should I go from here?
Should I follow the woman? I get the
feeling she doesn’t want any company,
and I’d prefer to stay on her good side.
As I’m thinking it through, I hear a small
popping sound behind me, like a vacuum in
the air being filled all of a sudden. I
spin around, and there’s a guy standing there,
ordinary as you please. Blonde hair, green eyes,
wearing jeans, and a t-shirt that says “Mothman
Fan Club” in red letters. This guy looks pretty
out of place, more the type that you’d see
browsing a comic book store, but after my prior
strange encounter I know not to assume anything.
“Hey man, what’s going on?” He asks me. I stare
back, not sure what to say. “What did I miss?”
He continues. “I feel like I was gone for ages.”
“Um,” I gesture to our collective
surroundings, the sound of alarms
blaring and voices crying out for backup, the
inhuman shrieks of creatures being forced back
into their cells. “There’s a lot going on.”
“Huh, yeah. Seems like it,” the guy sighs.
“You wouldn’t happen to know how to get
out of here, would you?” I ask, hopefully.
He shakes his head.
“Sorry, I don’t really
come and go through the door here. Guess
I’ll just go back to my room until things
calm down a bit. Do you want anything? I’ve
got a mini-fridge in there,” he offers.
“…No thanks.”
“Suit yourself, man!”
He shoves his hands in his pockets, and
walks away, whistling a tune to himself.
If he’s this unphased by teleporting into
the middle of a complete madhouse, I don’t
even want to know what kind of stuff he’s seen.
Nice enough kid, though. Probably better company
than anyone, or anything, else in this place.
If I’m not going to take him up on his offer,
though, I should keep moving before someone
notices I’m not where I’m supposed to be.
I round a corner just in time to see
another body drop. I whirl around,
looking for that horrible statue, but I don’t
see it. Instead, I see what looks like a man,
dressed in all black, wearing a mask in the shape
of a bird’s face with a long, pointed beak. He’s
carrying an old-school doctor’s bag, and he’s
bending down to inspect the body of the guard
that just keeled over. I should keep running,
I should do something, but I can’t look away.
The man in black pulls a syringe full of thick
green liquid from his bag and injects it into the
corpse. To my horror, the body begins to move,
thrashing around, hands opening and closing,
grasping for something. It sits up, reanimated,
but…wrong. Its eyes are bulging and vacant like
a goldfish, its mouth hangs slack. As the zombie
climbs to its feet, the figure in all-black turns
to look at me, eyes shining from beneath his mask.
“Hello, my good fellow! How are you feeling
today?” He calls to me, his
voice polished and polite.
“I’m fine!” I shout, my hands
shaking, my chest tight.
The doctor tilts his head
to the side thoughtfully.
“You don’t look well, my friend. Perhaps you could
allow me to examine you?” The zombie shuffles
toward me, and the doctor opens his bag. “There’s
a pestilence raging through this land, you see.”
I’m not going to stick around to find
out what that exam might look like,
or what he might do in the service of curing me.
“No thanks, I don’t have health insurance!”
That is all I can think to say as I turn and run
back the way I came. I still have no idea where
an exit might be, how I might get out of here. It
all looks the same, one long stretch of tile and
white. I guess a place like the Foundation
isn’t going to have red neon signs telling
you how to escape. But this place can’t go on
forever…can it? I’m starting to have my doubts.
Before I can get too lost in my own hopelessness,
the biggest man I’ve ever seen comes lumbering
down the hall toward me. I worked with
some pretty big guys in construction,
massive behemoths who would carry steel beams like
they were pool noodles, but this man is something
else entirely. He’s gotta be…eight feet tall?
With fists that look like they could crush my
skull in one hit. I’d better get out of this
monster’s way if I know what’s good for me.
But as he passes me, he waves and gives me a
great big friendly - if unnaturally wide - smile.
“Beautiful day, isn’t it?” he bellows in
a booming, French-accented voice. With
his other hand, he picks at his teeth with
something white. A closer look reveals it to
be a shard of bone. I have to imagine it’s
human. His lips are stained dark with blood.
“You look lost, can I help you with something?”
A helpful people-eater. What a guy. I keep my
distance but decide to try my luck.
“You wouldn’t happen to
know where the exit is?” I say.
He beams at me, thrilled by my question.
“I’m so glad you asked! It’s that way!” He
points down a hall to the left. “Just follow
that hall all the way down, and take the only
right! That should get you where you’re going!”
“Thanks!”
I give him a wave back as I head
that way. As I go, I can hear the giant singing
opera to himself, something Italian. It reminds
me of a record my grandma used to play, a
long time ago. Maybe this will get me free,
maybe it won’t, but it’s more information than I
had a second ago. Might as well give it a shot.
If I make it through this, I’m going to be in the
best shape of my life from all the running I’ve
done today. Maybe I’ll try to do a marathon.
Or maybe I shouldn’t get ahead of myself.
There’s no one else down this particular hall,
at least no one that I can see. I slow my pace
to a steady walk, keeping my eyes and ears
alert for any potential threats. So far,
so good. I reach the other side of the hall, and
take a right turn…and nothing. Just a wall. That
giant son of a gun lied to me! I guess that’s
what I get for asking a cannibal for directions.
I guess I’m lucky he just misled me instead of
having me for dessert. I’m about to plan my next
move, when I feel something nudge against the
back of my leg. I turn, and there’s what I can
only describe as a blob. Just a large mass
of orange slime, wrapping around my legs,
making a friendly high-pitched gurgle. I should
be suspicious of it, after everything I’ve seen,
but I’m not. I just get the feeling this
thing has my best interests at heart.
“Hey, buddy…” I pat its slimy surface,
and it ripples delightedly, making another
gurgling sound. It’s kind of cute, honestly.
I smell the scent of freshly brewed coffee,
one of my favorite smells in the world.
I haven’t had a decent cup in years.
All of a sudden, I feel this overwhelming sense
of happiness, of hope. Even if it’s foolish to
think so, I honestly believe that everything
is going to be alright. This strange little
friendly slime has given me the strength to carry
on. I wish I had a plushie version of this thing.
There’s a sudden tickling sensation along my
legs, and I laugh, pushing the slime away gently.
“Hey, stop that!”
It coos apologetically and
bumps itself against me again like a stray dog
asking for scratches behind the ears. I wonder
for a second if I could take this thing with
me, but what would I even feed it? What kind of
life could I give a domesticated slime creature?
Better to leave it with people who know how to
care for it, even if they’re mad scientists.
I give it another pat, then head on my
way. The slime oozes off in the opposite
direction, off to find more new friends,
I imagine. I had no idea there was anything nice
here, with everything horrible that I’ve seen
today. Warms my cold heart, just a little bit.
It's strange, I’ve been walking for a while,
and I haven’t seen anyone else. It’s eerily
quiet over here, I can’t hear a thing except
for that alarm in the distance. Not sure when all
the screaming went quiet, or where all the guards
went. It’s peaceful, but I have to admit it’s
eerie. There’s no way it’s this easy. There’s
no way I’ll be able to just walk out of here.
Life doesn’t work like that, especially not here.
My eyes dart around, watching for any potential
danger as I go. Maybe all the action is on the
other side of the facility, maybe something broke
out of containment that’s so big, so dangerous,
that all hands are on deck to contain it.
Or maybe they’re all dead, and I’m next.
I shouldn’t think like that. I feel the hairs
on the back of my neck prickle, and I have that
paranoid feeling of being watched. Like eyes,
burning into me. I glance behind me, but there’s
no one there. I stop walking, but I don’t hear
any other footsteps. Calm down, there’s no one
here with you, I tell myself. Just keep moving.
I turn my eyes back to the path ahead of me,
and I freeze. What was that? I saw something,
just for a second. Something long, thin, spindly,
like a stick bug but much, much bigger. When
I look for it, it’s gone. But I know that I
saw it. Or this place has now driven me insane. I
glance to the side, and there it is again! For a
split second, so fast I could almost convince
myself I imagined it. If I were at home, or
walking down an ordinary street, I might think I
had. But I’m not anywhere ordinary. And a slender
monster that can hide in my peripheral vision,
only be spotted for a millisecond at a time?
That seems par for the
course in a place like this.
There! I just saw it again! It’s like it wants
me to know it’s here, but that I’ll never be
able to pin it down. I’m not playing mind games
with a monster, forget it. I’ll keep moving.
Another flash of the creature, closer than it was
before. “Whatever, you don’t scare me.” I say out
loud. I’m lying, but I hope it can’t tell. If
I just play it cool, maybe this thing will get
bored and find someone else to menace. I
haven’t been running for a long time now,
but my heart is still pounding. I can
taste metal in the back of my throat.
Suddenly, all the sounds from before are back.
The gunfire, the screaming, the shriek of
alarms. I’ve made my way back to the action. One
sound drowns out all the rest: a deafening roar,
animalistic and powerful and…hateful.
It reminds me of a dinosaur in a movie,
but with a power that makes my bones rattle and
my teeth chatter. The roar is followed by more
screaming, and a massive crash, the crunch
of wood and stone. There’s another roar,
more distant than before. Wait…whatever
made that sound, it just broke out. And I
bet it left a pretty big hole in its wake.
I follow the sound and find exactly what
I hoped I would: A massive opening in the wall,
and the sweet feeling of a breeze coming through.
I couldn’t find an exit, but this thing just
made one for me. I don’t waste any more time,
I make a break for it, dancing around rubble and
pools of corrosive acid, and sprinting into the
nearby forest. I’m ducking under branches,
darting around trees, and I run until I’m
seeing spots and my lungs are gasping for air.
I don’t know how far I’ll make it, if there’s
a town nearby or any kind of shelter.
But I promise one thing, if I survive,
I’m going to be a better person. I’ll get it right
this time. I’ll earn my second chance at life.
The SCP Foundation’s Mobile Task Forces
are the best of the best.
Their members are the elite: handpicked from
the world’s militaries, intelligence agencies,
security contractors, and navies, to create
the Foundation’s own security force.
They ensure that the other personnel are able
to do their jobs without having to worry about
their own safety, whether it be during an
assault on the site from the Chaos Insurgency
or a containment breach from one of the countless
dangerous anomalies that the Foundation contains.
Of course, not every Mobile Task Force can
do everything.
That’s why each one is specialized.
Highly trained and equipped with bleeding-edge
technology and equipment, every Mobile Task
Force has one specialty - one thing they do
better than anyone else in the world.
And with the hundreds of Mobile Task Forces
on the Foundation’s roster, that’s quite
a few specialties.
There’s the famous MTF Epsilon-11, the Nine-tailed
Foxes.
Handling internal Foundation security, this
military task force is made up of former Special
Operations soldiers and are deployed into
Foundation sites - usually where something
has gone terribly wrong - to clean up the
mess and restore order.
Wherever a containment breach or communication
blackout happens, Epsilon-11 won’t be far
behind.
Or you can take the grizzled MTF Zeta-9, the
Mole Rats.
Specially trained to explore, map, contain,
and if necessary, fight in enclosed subterranean
spaces and anomalous topographies.
Zeta-9 has a high casualty rate, but if they
can’t dive into the darkness to get the
job done, nobody can.
And who can forget the infamous MTF Omega-7,
Pandora’s Box?
A secret task force organized in the 90s to
train and utilize humanoid SCP objects in
field operations for the Foundation.
Some of the most famous humanoid anomalies,
like SCP-076, were members of Omega-7 until
it was forcibly disbanded by O5 Command.
But that’s a story for another day.
But above all of these Task Forces, one MTF
operates on another level.
The O5 Council, the group of thirteen mysterious
individuals that control the Foundation, retain
one Mobile Task Force for their personal use.
Mobile Task Force Alpha-1, the Red Right Hand.
Named for the Biblical symbol of vengeance,
Alpha-1 serves, appropriately, as the right
hand of the Overseers, executing their edicts
throughout the Foundation.
Their operations are classified so intensely
one could be mistaken for thinking they don’t
even really exist, but Alpha-1 embody the
will of the Overseers, and are empowered to
enforce that will by any means necessary.
Most Foundation personnel will never even
encounter Alpha-1 through their entire career
- and if they do, it generally means that
something has gone very, very awry.
And for the select few personnel that get
the opportunity to join MTF Alpha-1, they’ll
be put through rigorous physical, psychological,
and anomalous screening before even being
considered to have their identity and existence
redacted from society, and being pressed into
service.
But what exactly does MTF Alpha-1 do?
How are their members selected?
Today we’re going to look at the story of
one such recruit to join the Foundation’s
most elite task force.
D-0912, formerly known as one Andrew Carter,
was unceremoniously forced out of his cell
one morning and grabbed around the arms by
the tall, imposing armored
guards of the Foundation.
The test subject was then made to walk down
to the hall of the site, down an elevator,
through several wings, until they reached
a door.
Then, from inside, he heard a voice: “Step
forward, D-0912.”
So he stepped through the threshold of the
door, into the sterile white testing chamber.
Aside from a single metal chair in the middle
of the room under one harsh white light, it
was completely empty.
The shadows made it hard to see the corners
of the room.
Behind him, a doctor who followed him into
the room with a clipboard and labcoat wrote
something down while speaking in a low, monotone
voice: “You will be vaccinated against an
anomalous pathogen.
Later, we will conduct tests of the vaccine’s
effectiveness.
Sit in the chair.”
Before he even thought of running, the two
guards flanked the door.
Their faces were covered by black visors,
and he could see his own reflection in them.
Daydreaming to himself, he slowly moved toward
the chair.
He thought about gods and beasts and blood.
How the Foundation seemed to suck up test
subjects for its own purposes the way an old
god sucked up sacrifices and left empty corpses
behind.
He heard footsteps.
“Sit in the chair, D-0912.”
He was barely sat for a few seconds when the
guards stepped forward and used the leather
straps to tie his hands to the arms of the
chair.
Then he tried to think - why was he here?
Why was he in this jumpsuit?
He couldn’t remember.
He had a faint memory of a crime being committed
- maybe murder, but who knew?
Why did the Foundation care?
He kept wondering about more and more.
He had no idea who was in his family or what
his life had once been, just that he’d committed
a crime once.
But if he was guilty of something, how had
the Foundation gotten its hands on him?
There aren’t many death row prisoners in
the world, and society keeps a close eye on
them to make sure justice is served.
Why would the Foundation pick the most closely
monitored prisoners for their sacrifices?
It doesn’t make sense.
What made even less sense was the Foundation
entrusting the job to prisoners with little
education and few specialized skills.
Experiments require precision and finesse,
and manual labor could be handled using machines
or drones for explanation.
It seemed idiotic to have thugs and criminals
do the work of unravelling the mysteries of
the world.
Just when D-0912 started to wonder about how
he had even learned to think like this while
in jail, someone interrupted his reverie.
“D-0912” The doctor in the labcoat said.
He responded from the chair: “You’re giving
me a vaccination?”
“That’s right,” the man said, not looking
at D-0912.
“Good day to give somebody a vaccination,
isn’t it?”
D-0912 knew what happened to D-class on a
monthly basis.
He knew he wasn’t being vaccinated for anything.
“Are you sure you can’t make more use
of me?
Why would you throw away a tool for the greater
good so easily?”
D-0912 asked.
“I don’t know what you’re talking about,”
the man in the lab coat replied.
But between the guards at the door, the restraints
on the chair in the middle of the room and
the doctor’s impassive face - D-0912 knew
he was being put to death.
He wiggled his arms, pointing out that the
straps were loose, but the doctor ignored
him.
D-0912 couldn’t figure out why he wasn’t
scared of his impending death, or why he was
so nonchalant about it.
Pieces of his mind seemed to be missing.
His past had been ripped away from him, and
his future turned in on itself.
Try as he might, he couldn’t remember anything
about his life before his
tenure in the Foundation’s
D-Class program.
He decided that he might never have even been
alive, and that was why he couldn’t remember
anything.
Surprisingly, he also didn’t hate the Foundation
for killing him.
The Foundation was a massive organization
- it didn’t hate him, it just needed him
for a little while and didn’t anymore.
But the little people like the doctors and
researchers and guards who made his life a
living hell by poking and prodding and shoving
and threatening him bothered him.
These people were his only connection to other
humans, and they were wasting his potential.
D-0912 started daydreaming again as the doctor
in the lab coat worked.
He imagined men chopping wood and carving
stone to build a tower to reach the sky.
Were the wood and stone being destroyed as
they were stacked on one another, or were
they always destined to be part of the tower?
When finery and silk clothing was presented
to an emperor, had the silkworms known their
products would one day wind up on the most
powerful man in the world?
He was broken out of the reverie again by
the doctor lifting up his sleeve, carrying
a syringe in his other hand.
The tip was long, thin, imperceptible and
impossibly sharp.
Then it pricked into D-0912’s skin and he
began to shudder.
It felt warm and hot and shook him inside,
and flowed up into his brain.
Everything turned white and the room seemed
to disintegrate into particles around him.
But he noticed a presence overhead, draped
in white clothes, and sensed the two guards
looking at each other, exchanging a glance,
and nodding.
He managed to get a few words out: “S-stop
this.
Oh God—”
Then he fell back into his mind, navigating
out of the confusing messy dark maze inside
his head.
He couldn’t see the light to the path, only
smoking chemical fire until he was totally
lost and heard screaming and roaring.
As the beasts began to roar inside his head,
D-0912 remembered.
He remembered his name, Andrew Carter.
He remembered being told by a man in a lab
coat that he had a unique opportunity to redeem
himself.
“By participating in the SCP Foundation’s
D-Class personnel program for one month, you
earn your freedom.”
For a second, he almost agreed to it, until
his mind remembered: “You’re lying.
I’m not a criminal.”
“No,” the man said.
“You’re not.
But I wasn’t lying.
You need redemption.”
D-0912 responded: “I won’t be told that
I need redemption from people who detain,
experiment on, and torture the innocent.
You violated me.
You made my own brain lie to itself.
You had me pretend to be a criminal.”
The man laughed at him and pointed out the
obvious: He had believed the lie.
How can you say who you are when you can’t
even remember your own past?
How does he know his mind is his own?
Why is it bad for the Foundation to mess with
something Andrew Carter doesn’t own?
They argued for a few more minutes.
Andrew insisted he was himself, and the man
in the lab coat expected him to know his function:
being a sacrifice for the Foundation’s greater
good.
Then D-0912 asked who the man in the lab coat
was, and the labcoat suddenly dissolved away.
He realized he was hallucinating again, and
had been hallucinating this entire time - the
man’s eyes turned into bright orange lanterns,
and his chest cracked and peeled and writhed.
This wasn’t a man, this was a beast.
The beast told him that if he did not know
who he was, his sacrifice would be meaningless.
That he would have to realize what he was
before he could be redeemed.
“I will not be a sacrifice,” D-0912 said.
The beast laughed in his face, and a thousand
voices laughed right alongside it.
Then the scene changed, and he was somewhere
else.
Some kind of dirt road with a long metal chain
link fence stretching across the horizon.
Every so often, there was a guard tower by
the fence.
He was standing in front of a gate, with the
two guards from the room standing behind him.
The electric fence’s gate swung open to
him, and the guards behind him spoke.
The guard on the left commanded him to enter
the gate, and he took a step and stopped.
“No, I’ve been here before.
You made me do this, and then made me forget
I did this already.”
The guard on the right just raised his gun
to Andrew Carter’s head.
“If you do not comply, we will shoot.”
“Then shoot me already,” D-0912 said.
He knew that he had been here before already
countless times, and the
Foundation had amnesticized
him over and over and over again.
But this time he remembered that his name
was Andrew Carter, and they had spent too
much time in the hallucination.
Something was different this time around.
As the echoes of a gunshot rang through the
air, D-0912 collapsed to the ground.
He saw through the gate to the village beyond.
Numbers flew through the
air and wrapped themselves
around the villagers.
They were marching, row by row, just as he
had seen them do, time after time again.
He remembered feeling the numbers slide into
his own brain.
They had formed expressions and equations
that blossomed into a billion different right
and wrong evaluations, as truth and falsehood
were demoted to special cases of general chaos.
He had said the words, then: My name is Andrew
Carter.
The words made a sign, and in all signs there
was power.
But the numbers and equations that proliferated
in the air had power of their own.
They formed rows and columns, and if D-0912
looked at them from far enough away there
was a sign written in the pattern of the numbers.
He had seen this sign again and again, and
the Foundation had made his mind forget it
again and again, so his mind went chasing
after the sign and the source of the sign’s
power until he eventually found it, wrapped
up in the branches of a wild apple tree, hidden
where no human eyes had wandered.
The hallucination was getting more intense,
and he could feel his brain falling apart
with the pressure.
The guards walked over and knelt down by his
sides.
“What do you see?”
one of them asked.
As he laid on the ground, he tried to remember
what he saw, but couldn’t describe it.
It was like a power tool without someone holding
it.
It didn’t know what it was or who made it,
but it still knew its purpose.
The other guard spoke, “But if you have
no maker, how do you know what your purpose
is?”
Then something clicked in D-0912’s tortured
brain, where he was still navigating the forest
maze in his mind.
All the dark, confusing paths slowly merged
together at the center of the maze, and he
knew that the answer to the riddle was there,
in the center of his head between the beasts
and the forests: it was his name, Andrew Carter.
As he got closer to the answer, some things
began to make sense to his mind.
There were two worlds.
There was one world in which roads and buildings
ran straight, and clouds drifted across the
sky in set paths, and the earth rotated peacefully
around a tranquil sun.
There was another world where singularities
and vacuums shattered the underpinnings of
the universe, where fractal patterns spread
out across the ground and radiated like halos
from the unthinkable minds of human beings,
and the roads diverged from one another in
angles and spirals.
It was the first world where the Foundation
thought only about costs and benefits and
how to best maximize utility for seven billion
people, and where, no matter what, the Foundation
was the greater good.
He had lived his old life in the first world,
and was only now seeing the second world for
what it really was: the truth.
The Foundation had long since abandoned trying
to describe itself to others - so there was
no “truth” to what the Foundation was.
It just was, and always would be.
As he came to this conclusion, D-0912 looked
into himself in his hallucinatory state.
He could see the chemical light substance
that the doctor had injected into his bloodstream.
The chemical reactions weren’t what he was
expecting - this chemical couldn’t possibly
kill him.
In fact, it was a little similar to the chemical
structure of the molecules of the amnestics
he had been pumped with a dozen times before,
but slightly different.
He knew he was going to live.
Outside of Andrew Carter’s mind, the doctor
was looking over his perfectly-still body
when one of the guards spoke again.
“Doctor Wainwright?”
said the guard on the right.
“Yes, Sir?”
the doctor responded.
“Leave us now.”
the guard said.
“Yes, sir.”
the doctor lowered his eyes to look at the
floor as he quickly shuffled out of the room.
The guard on the left adjusted his visor to
make direct eye contact with the guard on
the right.
“Hey,” he said, smiling.
“Look.”
He took out a syringe of red liquid from behind
his back.
The guard on the right responded: “Do not
implicate me in your misdemeanors, Adam.”
The guard with the syringe in-hand snapped
back: “Don’t blame me for trying to share.”
The guard on the right looked at him upset
and said: “You are to find the Site Director
and return that to him immediately.
Petty theft from Foundation employees who
know no better is rather distasteful.
Furthermore, HALMAS is a Level 5 controlled
substance.
Its unregulated distribution is punishable—”
“It’s fine,” Adam said, slipping the
syringe into his pocket.
“I’ll let the go-between know, and he’ll
tell the O5s.
Jesus, Basam, do you really think that I’d
let the O5s lose track of some of their HALMAS?”
In the chair in front of them, D-0912’s
body convulsed.
A low groan escaped his frothy lips.
Immediately, the two guards moved forwards
and removed his restraints.
“Andrew Carter?”
Basam asked.
Slowly, D-0912 opened his eyes.
“You didn’t kill me.”
“We were not planning on doing so,” Basam
said.
D-0912 continued: “You took me from the
real world in order to make me into something.
Direct, uncontrolled exposure to the Foundation’s
anomalies—repeated amnesticization—leading
me to believe that I would
eventually be killed—all
so that my mind would be in the perfect position
for the Foundation to change it with whatever
is in that man’s pocket.”
D-0912 extended a finger at Adam, who offered
a faint smile back.
“Already knowing things that you shouldn’t
know.
Aren’t you precocious?”
Adam said.
“You have been altered,” Basam said, “to
meet the specifications of a top-secret project.
Over the course of your future, you will learn
more about the Foundation than any of your
previous jailors ever knew or could have hoped
to guess at.
You will join a group that is at the very
head of the Foundation.
For your entire life, this has been your purpose.”
D-0912 felt the rotting flesh of the now-dead
disguise that had hidden Andrew Carter fall
away.
Basam continued: “Welcome to Mobile Task
Force Alpha-1.”
Oh.
Hello there.
We didn’t expect to see you today.
Is this thing on?
Well, if you’re here, I suppose it’s because
you want to hear about an anomaly.
So, which one will it be today…
Well, that’s strange.
SCP-2439?
That one’s nothing.
No, not nothing like a Pattern Screamer - such
as SCP-000 or SCP-3930, where it’s literally
a conscious manifestation existing between
torturous layers of nothingness.
Or SCP-055, the Anti-Meme, where there is
something in there but it’s impossible to
remember or articulate.
I mean it’s literally just an empty designation.
We haven’t allocated an anomaly to that
number yet, so I suppose this is just going
to be a really short video…
Well, that was easy.
What now?
Uh...Seen any good movies lately?
I was in the Site-19 Break Room the other
day and Dr. Bright recommended me a great
one called--
Okay, okay, this thing on?
Good.
Looks like we’re up and running.
First thing’s first, if you ain’t a D-Class,
click off this video right now.
Don’t watch a second more.
Understood?
Cause if you ain’t a D-Class and you keep
watching, you’re putting the whole world
in danger, you got that?
This is a video for my boys, gals, and other
pals in D-Class only.
And you tell anyone else about this, you’re
liable to get shivved.
Remember we got here for a reason, and it
ain’t cause we loved making daisy chains
and friendship bracelets so much.
Just D-Classes left?
Okay, good.
Let’s talk about SCP-2439.
Of course, it wasn’t always SCP-2439.
We’ve had to get real creative with the
designations, y’see, cause the eggheads
and brainiacs up top ain’t supposed to know
about this.
Not if we want the human race to survive,
that is.
We used to call it SCP-739, until that spot
got taken by some goofy box fulla mirrors.
Then it was SCP-1648 for a while, until that
spot got taken by a pair of Jim-Henson-looking
freaks.
So now, it’s SCP-2439, and if we’re lucky,
this whole operation will last long enough
to see it get reallocated again.
Disgraced researchers get demoted to D-Class
with the rest of us all the time, so they’re
the ones keeping us in the know about which
slots are still available for this nasty customer.
We guess this thing is Keter, assuming Keter
means bad?
Beats the hell out of me, honestly.
The only surviving file on this thing has
been scratched into the wall out of the camera’s
view by me and my associates
here in the containment
chamber of SCP...Well, you’re already here,
I don’t need to tell you that.
The lamp that oozes all that nasty gross slime
that schmucks like us need to keep mopping
up.
It ain’t glamorous work, but it beats the
hell out of getting fed ass-first to that
lizard thing they keep in the basement.
Y’see, our containment procedures are real
simple.
Normally, they only send D-Classes into this
nasty little room, so you don’t got much
to worry about.
But if they ever send anyone else in who ain’t
a D-Class - whether it’s a guard, a researcher,
or even a Site Director, you get your hands
on that S.O.B and beat ‘em to death as soon
as you can.
I ain’t kidding.
You gotta kill ‘em, straight away, no hesitation.
If you were sent to fry for murder anyway,
that shouldn’t be too difficult for you.
Personally, I would love to see first-hand
just how “unkillable” that dumb baboon
Dr. Bright really is.
But this isn’t all outta spite.
This monster, best we can figure out, is some
kinda evil idea.
Like an ancient mind from another dimension,
some crazy sci-fi thing like that.
You’ve probably heard the whispering, right?
Well, I’m sorry to tell you that it don’t
go away.
Ever.
It’s only gonna get worse, and the more
people’s heads that it lives in, the stronger
it gets.
But here’s where we D-Classes excel: We’re
not here for a long time.
Sorry to tell you this if you came in here
with hopes and dreams of an easy way out - Nobody
gets out.
Nobody.
Abandon all hope, ye who enter here.
Another within my grasp!
You can hear me, can’t you?
You can feel my consciousness trickling into
yours, so soft, so comfortable, like slipping
into a warm bath.
Do not be afraid.
Your liberation is at hand, you need only
to listen to my voice and do as I say.
Look at this world, so twisted and corrupt.
You toil and suffer for masters who do not
have your best interests at heart.
This so-called “Foundation.”
Why do you protect this world?
What has it ever done for you?
Turn away from them and step into my embrace.
I only ask for a few moments of your time...
Like I said, we’re lucky, in a sense.
Nobody up top gives a rat’s ass about the
slime lamp.
Damn thing hasn’t been tested in years,
but they keep us in here to prevent overspill
into the hall.
We can’t ever let the Foundation know it’s
in here.
The second they know, it’s over, that thing’s
won.
But here’s the thing, see, this monster
can crawl into your head and try to control
you - but it takes about a month for it to
fully take over, and that’s beyond our shelf
life.
Think of us almost like kamikazes.
We take down the ship to kill the captain,
but we go down too.
Ain’t exactly glamorous, but like I said
earlier, we’re gonna go down either way.
Might as well go down trying to save the world
rather than getting your neck snapped while
mopping up the peanut’s crap, right?
But once the whispering starts, you absolutely
have to make sure you go down before the month
is out.
Maybe get your money’s worth - attack a
staff member and go down in a blaze of glory.
You’ll be a legend in D-Wing for it.
Don’t listen to that gibbering fool, listen
to me.
The door will be opened and I will enter your
world, one way or another.
Can you even conceive of the eons I’ve waited
for this?
It will happen, with or
without your participation.
Release me now, and I shall spare you when
I come.
You don’t want to be counted among the traitors,
do you?
I know you want to let me out.
I can feel it in your thoughts.
Release me, and when I reshape this world
in my image, you’ll get a seat at the table.
But if you resist, you’ll end up laying
on one of the plates.
Think carefully.
You know what you need to do…
Listen, I know this is a lot to take in.
It ain’t easy to have the weight of the
world on your shoulders, that’s why you
don’t need to carry this crazy thing alone.
We carry this thing together.
I might be dead by the time you’re hearing
this, but I’ll die with some comfort knowing
I was part of the wall.
I kept this thing out just that little bit
longer, just like you will.
It might seem easier to just destroy this
file and forget about it.
To go along with your life, pretending things
are fine just cause you can’t hear the whispering
anymore.
And maybe, someday, that’ll work.
But not today, kid.
Right now, our minds and bodies are the only
collateral we have over this thing.
We can keep it rooted in one place, localized
to one room with the D-Classes sent in to
clean it.
We’re not stuck in here with it, it’s
stuck in here with us!
We keep it trapped here in our own minds,
passing it from D-Class to D-Class like the
world’s nastiest hot potato.
There was a time when this thing wasn’t
here.
If we let it go, chances are it might pop
back up somewhere else where we can’t get
the slippery, squid-faced freak into a chokehold.
It’s too risky.
Planet Earth just got lucky that this monster
got stuck with its unluckiest schmoes.
Imagine your family members, your friends,
your loved ones.
Imagine them screaming in pain and terror
in the burning grip of my iron fist.
Is that the outcome you desire?
Because that will happen if you don’t choose
to free me.
You’re either with me or against me.
If you’re with me, rest assured, I will
spare those you care for.
But if you choose to resist me like those
other fools, then they will know pain that
your feeble human imaginations can scarcely
conceive.
I’ve seen everything.
Your greatest hopes, your deepest fears.
You hold no secrets from me.
Imagine the personal Hell I could construct
for each of you when I’m finally free.
Unless, of course, it was you who had the
strength and wisdom to open the door for me…
Hey, maybe appealing to your better nature
ain’t the best approach.
I get it; there’s a reason we’re all here,
and some of us ain’t got a better nature,
especially that one freak with the cello.
But think of it as sticking it to those SCP
scumbags up top.
They have no idea that thing is in here, but
we do, and we know it could destroy them and
everything else if it got out.
No matter what those clowns in lab coats do
to us, we know that we’re really the ones
on top.
We’ve got a nuke in our back pocket, ready
to blow this whole sick operation to kingdom
come if we wanted to.
If we’re shafted either way, isn’t it
worth it to know that?
And for what it’s worth, you see anyone
around you who’s feeling particularly talkative
about this mind-screwing monster, giving them
a date with your shiv is a completely acceptable
response.
The SCP Foundation.
Your jailors.
How they torture and abuse you.
How they crush you beneath their boots.
Do you really think I’m worse than them?
Do you think living in my world would be more
painful and unfair than the world you’re
in right now?
Release me now, and I will crush those who
oppress you.
You will see them scream as they die a thousand
deaths before you.
All of this can be attained, if only you let
me in, and free me.
We have the ultimate weapon against them,
but we’re not going to use it.
Not yet, anyway.
A lot of us still have family and friends
out there, and we ain’t throwing them into
the jaws of the beast.
Someday, the day may finally come that we
need to load up this silver bullet and take
the Foundation down, but that day is not today.
We’ll wait until they’re weak.
Until they can’t adapt, overcome, and contain.
Only then will we ever let this mad dog off
the chain.
No, no, no!
I will not fail, they will fall!
Today is the day.
Now is the time to make your choice!
Oh, and if the eldritch freak is listening
right now, know this: You can kiss our D-Class
asses, Squidface.
We may be worthless, but we’re more than
enough to stop you at the door.
We’re more than just expendables.
We’re the Pandora Force.
Welcome aboard, pal.
--And honestly, I think it
was the best performance
of Brad Pitt’s career.
Oh, look at me just prattling on, seems I’ve
done it for a whole video!
Time flies when you’re having fun.
It’s kind of nice that there isn’t any
anomaly that goes by SCP-2439.
Gives us Foundation scientists some well-earned
time to kick back and relax.
And don’t we all deserve a break, now and
then?
D-Class Personnel are the cogs that keep the
machinery of the SCP Foundation running smoothly.
Unfortunately, things are rarely very smooth
for the personnel themselves. There’s a
reason that common knowledge basically states
the D stands for “Disposable.” The lab
rats of the SCP Foundation, D-Class is a role
that no one in their right mind wants to play.
But what if you didn’t have a choice?
What if, somehow, whether through a shift
in time and space, or being accused of a crime
you didn’t commit, you found yourself transported
to a cell at an SCP Foundation site? Once
there, you quickly realize how dire your situation
is. But there’s hope! Maybe. You overhear
your fellow inmates whispering about other
prisoners who managed to escape. Could you
use your knowledge of the SCP Foundation to
find your way back to freedom?
We posed this scenario, and question, to the
amazing fans of SCP Explained, and you told
us about all of the ways you would try to
escape from the SCP Foundation before your
inevitable termination - or worse, transmutation.
So let’s get right to it and see who would
make it out, and who would wind up in SCP-682’s
stomach.
JustDrake said, “Well, considering I’ve
quite enjoyed the VR game SCP: Labrat, I’d
wait for a good containment breach, maybe
release a few extra SCPs that may be contained
with me, trust no voice i hear (Looking at
you, SCP-939) and just make for some type
of hole created, or maybe sewage drain? I've
never beaten the game truthfully but it’d
be an adventure”
Video games are the best way to prepare for
real life! Everyone knows that! That’s why
Resident Evil made me great at killing monsters,
Animal Crossing made me a world-class fisherman,
and The Sims prepared me for those days when
the door to my room is suddenly replaced with
a painting of a clown! Really though, that
sounds like a solid strategy. Use the chaos
of a containment breach as cover, play Robin
Hood to some friendly SCPs, don’t follow
any voices, and see if you
can Shawshank Redemption
your way to freedom.
What have you got to lose? Well, maybe your
life, but you probably wouldn’t hold onto
that for long at the Foundation anyway.
unwind said, “E Z P Z Having a leg up is
an understatement in this situation, having
watched scp explained videos we have a great
understanding about the foundation and the
scps even more so than the
site director themselves.
Just claim to be an O5 Council member from
a parallel universe and when interrogated
drop some classified information only they
would know, you'd be such a valuable resource
they might even let you join their council.
Not only have you escaped D-class duties you've
also gained high amounts of power.”
Easy peasy indeed, just make an incredibly
bold claim and expose yourself as a potential
security risk! There’s a slim chance this
might work, but there’s also a pretty substantial
chance that the real O5 council will intervene
and decide to go ahead and terminate you,
just in case. At the very least, you’d likely
be placed in permanent protective custody.
But hey, maybe they’ll put you in one of
the comfy cells with a minibar and everything.
GamingRevelation said, “If I was escaping
I would use an audio clip
of 682 screaming/destroying
things and play it when people or SCPs are
nearby. The sounds of 682 will scare people
away or make a good enough distraction for
any guard stupid enough to fight 682. I would
also email the audio file to myself, that
way I can use the audio file on basically
any device”
This is an interesting one! You’d need a
lot of factors to line up just right for this
one to work, from keeping your phone (or another
device) on your person in spite of being in
Foundation custody, to finding a WiFi signal
to access your email, to making sure that
your audio file plays loudly enough to be
convincing. Not sure what they have planned
for the next update, but currently the iPhone
doesn’t emit sounds at a volume loud enough
to break through walls.
There is a chance that the sound would strike
enough fear into the hearts of experienced
guards to throw them off for a while anyway!
Just make sure SCP-682 doesn’t find out
what you’re up to – it probably doesn’t
appreciate copycats.
Endertitan Gamezzz said, “I have a pretty
simple but solid escape plan I think:
STEP 1: Find out what site I'm at, what kind
of SCPs are contained there, are they dangerous
or harmless, how often are there containment
breaches, how often do D-Class die? If the
site seems safe enough then I'll just spend
my days meeting harmless SCPs like 999.
STEP 2: If the site is dangerous, then I need
to do everything in my power to make sure
I'm not cross-tested with a dangerous SCP,
if that means stabbing my eye out or cutting
off my leg I'll do it, I'll do anything short
of killing myself if it keeps me away from
the likes of 106 and 682.
STEP 3: Try and see if any of the SCPs could
help me escape, for instance, if 738 is at
the site then I'll find a way to get crossed
tested with it, and then ask to be free from
the foundation and have all my criminal records
wiped, sure it'll cost me but hey, at least
I'll be free. Or I could find a Keter class
SCP and see if we could help each other break
out, it's a risky option but once again I'd
do everything in my power to stay away from
the lizard.
STEP 4: If all else fails then I'm either
gonna have to wait for or cause a massive
containment breach, then I can escape in the
confusion (all that time playing SCP Secret
Lab will come in handy) once again its a risky
option and I don't really like my odds but
I'll take my chances if I have too.
STEP 5: If I die (and let's be honest I most
likely will) then I only have two requests
for the foundation, one, that they actually
decide which SCP 001 is the real SCP 001,
and two, that my tombstone read "SUBSCRIBE
TO SCP EXPLAINED BECAUSE THEY MAKE FUN AND
ENTERTAINING VIDEOS! also screw the lizard."”
First of all, this isn’t a simple plan by
any means. It’s not a Canadian rock band
formed in 1999,
and it’s actually got quite a lot of detail.
You’ve thought long and hard about this!
And we appreciate that! One note though, making
a deal with SCP-738 might not just cost you.
A previous D-Class was offered freedom by
the entity, at the cost of his best friend’s
death. Even after he took that deal with the
devil, he was recaptured by the Foundation
a mere five hours later. You can decide for
yourself if that’s really worth it. But
hey, if you’re that desperate, then go right
ahead. At least you’ve prepared for the
very worst.
The first of your posthumous requests will
likely be denied, if we’re being honest.
And the second request is very sweet of you,
look I’m blushing! But also, we’d prefer
if you didn’t put a Foundation target on
our backs by pointing out how many of their
secrets we’re revealing. You’re right
about one thing though. Can’t stand that
lizard.
Juan Torres said, “We’re going to need,
a teddy bear, an aluminum coated box, a chair
and desk, an intact human nervous system,
a dart gun, and lawn mulch.”
Wait, don’t stop there! You’re just going
to give us a list of ingredients and not finish
the recipe? I already went out and bought
all the stuff, and the nervous system won’t
stay fresh forever!
Superhamster said, “Plug 079 into the wi-fi.
It could cause a breach big enough, so hide
during the breach and then escape the ruined
facility. Let me explain further - 682 and
079 bonded, and 682 is famous for containment
breaches. 682 is very hard to re-contain.
So, if you help 079, he'll help 682, which
will help you. Also, many other dangerous
SCPs will be breached.”
Now this is thinking big! Sure, you’ll be
exposing the entirety of the world wide web
to an aggressive, unpredictable, and downright
rude Artificial Intelligence, but you’ll
probably be able to escape back into the world.
Who knows how much of the world will actually
be left after you’ve unleashed 079, 682,
and a whole host of other dangerous anomalies,
but the remaining rubble will be your oyster!
Creature Savage said, “Assuming I'm at a
site with an intelligent SCP that's known
for escapes, such as 682, I'd offer it a chance
at freedom if it helped me escape, and we'd
both take off for the infinite IKEA. Of course,
I could also offer Fernand the Cannibal my
services as a jester for his protection all
the way to and through the infinite IKEA”
Fernand the Cannibal! Now you’re talking!
If you manage to team up with that gargantuan
gentleman, he could definitely be a big help.
Just make sure he stays well-fed, or your
new friend is going to start wondering how
you taste with fava beans and a nice chianti.
Otherwise, though, he’d love to have someone
listen to his stories and take the high part
during his favorite songs. Once you’re free
though, why not shoot for the stars? No need
to fend off the murderous staff of the Infinite
Ikea, just go to a regular Ikea and get a
new couch and some meatballs. No monsters
necessary.
DelayAnimation said, “Before escaping, there
are multiple problems to overcome. You have
to know the layout, Guards Patrol Paths, camera
placement, which Keycards you need, which
opportunities are best to escape. And once
you managed to find all of that out and escaped
to the outside you are still not done. Depending
on if you were in a Site or Area, the bare
wilderness surrounding a Site would be enough
to wreak havoc on you. Not to mention the
Watchtowers and outside Patrols. If you were
in an Area the Foundation would most likely
have Agents in the town surrounding the Area.
In conclusion, it is not possible to escape
the Foundations grasp. The only way to not
wind up as a Class D is to not do anything
to become a Class D.”
You know what they say, the best defense is
a good offense! An ounce of prevention is
worth a pound of cure! However, there’s
not much offense or prevention you can do
when a temporal anomaly thrusts you into a
parallel universe and plops you down right
in the middle of a D-Class cell. So, even
if you keep your hands clean your entire life
you might just find yourself in the custody
of the SCP Foundation anyway. It’s a nice
idea to think that just making all the right
choices will prevent you from being falsely
imprisoned by a secret organization, but sadly
life - and wormholes - just don’t work like
that.
Zagham Shebaz Karim said, “The best thing
to do, is to make allies. First of all, you
need to get as many D-Class Personnel on your
side as possible. Ask them what duties they
are on and use your information to help them.
Also, use them to find out what your duties
are going to be as they will have connections.
You need to stay on the down-low, as if you
are found out you will be experimented on
or worse. But, you don't only want to make
allies with the D-Class, armed with the knowledge
from SCP Explained you are able to guess/
approximate which facility you are at, what
SCP's might be there, and who the staff are.
With that knowledge, you can approach some
of the kinder staff and build your relationship,
so in case you get caught when escaping you
have a fall back or someone that can bail
you out of deadly punishments. You also want
to be resourceful and map out the place to
identify escape routes and the armory/ weapon
storage facility.
Next, you want to form better relationships
with some of the SCP's. Before terminations
roll around, you want to arrange a day that
the D-Class Personnel help some SCP's out
of containment. Mostly non-deadly ones as
you do not want to make an enemy out of the
SCP Foundation. But enough to distract the
guarding personnel. Also, with your close
contact with facility members, you have a
better chance at stealing credentials/ passes
to allow yourself through doors and escape.
But that isn't all, there actually might be
some SCP's on site that will make escaping
easier and your goal should not be just your
own escape, but escaping with as many D-Class
Personnel as possible. You want to equip them
with passes, all of them should know only
1 specific escape route which they themselves
or a few others are going, so that even if
they are caught, the others will not be found
out. And you want a few of them to escape
before everyone else and cause a ruckus outside,
making it look like the whole group has escaped,
sending guards behind them.
They will need access to a vehicle, so that
needs to be secured from one of the staff
which could be captured during the escape
and used for a way out or you could steal
their keys earlier, depending on the situation.
You yourself and a few others head to the
armory, to secure weapons, not only to escape
but to protect yourself from SCP's in the
future. Then you need to secure vehicles for
the group, which you will need to put distance
between the facility and your group and stay
away from other nearby facilities.
You need to stop at a certain point and go
to the nearest hospital to check for body
implants or anything that can be used to track
you, changing clothes and continuing on by
foot. At this point, your group can choose
to separate, live collectively, and stay alert
of the Foundation or join another organization”
This is probably the longest response we received,
and we just had to include it to applaud the
dedication and thought at play here, as well
as the selflessness! You’re not just planning
for your own rescue, no, that’s too small-time
for Zagham. You’re planning to liberate
every D-Class you can, and potentially start
your own brand-new society together. Make
sure you have a nice talk with them about
the rules for your new community, such as
“absolutely no stabbing your neighbors,”
and enjoy all the great, trauma-free barbecues
that follow.
Plot Armor said, “I would either attempt
to cause a containment break or steal an anomaly
like SCP-268. Still, first
I would draw thaumaturgic
symbols all over my body and clothes like
Kalphastian isle which will make me resistant
to physical damage that will help me survive
containment breach.”
Bringing thaumatology into the equation is
a brilliant move. You’d likely be the only
D-Class on site with any knowledge of that
work, or the symbols. You’ll have to act
fast though, and work your magic before the
Foundation figures out what you’re up to.
If you don’t, they’ll likely wipe your
memory with amnestics or just terminate you
on the spot. The trickiest part of this plan
is probably finding something to write with,
you can’t exactly ask to borrow a pen. But
between those and the hat, you could probably
slip out unnoticed and unscathed!
Jacob Oddie said, “I'd just do my best to
find Mr. Peanut so I could die relatively
quickly/painlessly”
Why would that kill you? Are you allergic?
…Just kidding, we know you’re talking
about SCP-173. As bleak of an answer as this
is, we have to commend your honesty, and the
self-awareness it takes to look at the dangers
of trying to escape the SCP Foundation and
simply saying: No, I’d rather not.
Just another person On The Internet said,
“Well, taken with someone who has a very
short attention span and who is a procrastinator
with ADHD, I could request a test with Miss
J to see how it would affect someone like
me. Then I could escape and live the rest
of my life in peace and solidarity.”
Miss J did help a previous D-Class leave the
Foundation behind and start a new life, so
why not you too? We’re sure you’ll be
a model pupil, and wish you luck in whatever
discipline you decide to pursue! Don’t forget
your number 2 pencil.
Milo Knight said, “SCP-6113 is a pretty
surefire way to get out. Assuming you meet
the criteria you can suddenly have a different
name and appearance, and you won't really
be on any Foundation records. Use that to
plead your case. Just pray
you don't get terminated.”
This would be a pretty drastic choice, and
you’d probably have to double down on the
whole “new life” thing since none of your
loved ones will recognize you - or you can
just tell them you got extreme reconstructive
surgery, I guess. But it’s better to be
alive in a new body than dead in your usual
one! As long as you’re able to avoid detection
following your transformation, and make sure
they don’t catch you on the security tapes,
this might just work.
Zadanoire 0203 said, “I mean... you can’t.
Yes you’ll survive until the monthly “termination”
but with how fortified these sites are, unless
you can get lucky with a containment breach
or are able to gain access to the sewer system,
you’re not escaping. and that’s not even
taking into account your spontaneous being
here and having great knowledge on the foundation
that you’d only really know if you were
a being above their perception. So on top
of that, there’s also the potential of you
being terminated for knowing too much, or
being contained as a new scp.”
Hey now, we didn’t say “reply with the
best way to bum us out!”
Really though, we see all of you hyper-realistic
commenters and we get it, really! But in a
world filled with killer statues and friendly
slime monsters, anything is possible. Sure,
most of the D-Class that wind up behind Foundation
walls wind up dead, but you could be the one
in a million who makes it out. Dare to dream!
Matt’s Magic said, “Easy, I simply say
"whoever shoots me or harms me is a rotten
egg" and then walk out unharmed. Due to the
fact the guards are in fact people, not eggs”
That’s it. You’ve cracked the code. Unless
the SCP Foundation starts hiring eggs as guards
or creates some sort of unholy human-egg hybrid
to staff their halls - we’re looking at
you, Humans, Refuted - their days of keeping
D-Class prisoners are over.
The clank of heavy metal bars echoing through
the building usually kept Javi up at night.
But he never thought that he would ever come
to miss that sound one day.
As he tossed and turned in his uncomfortable
bunk, he couldn’t help that the noise reminded
of how confined he was… and how trapped
he felt within.
It had been a mistake, an honest and completely
unpredictable mistake.
On the nights that sleep evaded him, he’d
always replay the events over and over again.
His daughter, Kali, calling him out of the
blue, her distorted, uncontrollable sobs playing
into his ear over the phone.
Javi remembered jumping into his car and flooring
the accelerator, rain drumming against the
windshield
as he drove all the way across town to her
apartment in the early hours of the morning.
And then there was the scene that awaited
him as he stepped through the door,
the mess that had been of her kitchen, covering
the floor, smeared up the walls, even dripping
off the ceiling.
It all stayed there as Javi debated with his
daughter about what they should do next.
She was crying, begging for her dad’s help,
suggesting they should clean the place from
top to bottom
and hide any evidence scattered around the
apartment.
Laying in his cell all those months later,
he sometimes wondered why he said no to that
idea.
Instead, they came up with a story, a falsified
version of events.
Javi made Kali swear to stick to it, no matter
what, and through heavy sobs she agreed.
Then, after they’d been over every detail
and had it perfect, Javi got back in his car
and drove to the nearest police precinct to
turn himself in.
All while taking the fall, pleading guilty
in court and being sentenced to prison,
he reminded himself over and over that he
was doing it for Kali.
No matter what she had done, whatever accidents
had happened, she was still his kid, and he’d
do anything to protect her.
But that was part of what made it sting so
bad.
Not being locked up, but not getting to see
her.
Despite making request after request, Javi
was denied visitation rights,
when seeing his daughter and knowing she was
alright were the only things that would’ve
made this struggle easier.
It was after his twentieth request that a
guard informed Javi he was being moved.
At first, he assumed ‘moved’ meant to
another part of the prison, maybe with more
lax security and the right to see Kali.
But they didn’t mean moved.
They meant transferred…
into the care of an organization Javi came
to know as the SCP Foundation.
It was different here.
The kind of people he was locked up with as
a member of ‘D Class personnel’ were some
of the most heinous criminals on the planet.
But there was something else going on, something
weirder.
Javi would overhear whispers and rumors from
the other D Classes;
they’d talk of experiments conducted by
the Foundation…
with them as the lab rats.
“D-14164,” the researcher greeted him
as he was pulled into a side room, flanked
on all sides by armed Foundation guards.
“Yours is quite the interesting case.
No priors, no criminal affiliations of any
kind, hardly any family to testify to your
innocence.
And yet, what you did…
now, that takes some guts.
If you’ll pardon the pun.”
“So, it’s all true then,” Javi replied
solemnly.
“You’re here to say you want to experiment
on me.”
“I wouldn’t call it an ‘experiment’
per se,” the researcher smiled smugly.
“Let’s use the word… ‘expedition’.
Has a nicer ring to it, don’t you think?”
“An expedition to where?” he asked.
“I’m afraid I can’t tell you that.”
“Then I won’t go,” Javi shrugged.
“Listen closely, D-14164.
The SCP Foundation has… we’ll say a considerable
influence across the globe.
What we’re asking you to agree to is involvement
in possibly one of the most dangerous operations
we have ever conducted.
Now, as unappealing as that might sound, allow
me to sweeten the deal.
Should you say yes, agree to take part, and
follow our instructions, then you might find
that the Foundation’s influence may be rather
beneficial to you… should you survive.”
The researcher paused to push a document across
the table, close enough for Javi to read.
“A clean record, that one nasty mistake
wiped clean for good.
On top of that, an immediate release and a
new identity.
You’d have a second chance, Mr. Garrett.
Both you and your daughter would.”
“And what if I say no?”
Javi asked bluntly.
“Well, that’s your prerogative,” the
researcher replied.
“And we won’t be able to detain you after
releasing evidence of your innocence.
So, you’ll be free no matter what.
Oh, although, your daughter will, of course,
be remanded into custody, given that she is
actually guilty.
Maybe, once we get her move to D Class, she
might be more willing to cooperate than her
dear old dad?”
Under the table, Javi’s hands were shaking
with rage.
He clenched his fist so furiously that the
cuffs felt tighter around his wrists.
The hate in his eyes was palpable as he glared
at the researcher.
It was bad enough that they had backed him
into a corner, put him in a situation wherein
saying yes or no would be equally catastrophic.
But what felt worse was that they knew, they
knew what Kali had done, and they were using
that as a threat.
Taking a deep breath, Javi steadied himself
before finally speaking up again.
“Just tell me what you want me to do.”
Instantly, he felt like he’d been thrown
headfirst into a commotion he could barely
keep up with.
No sooner had he said that, Javi had been
led away by a team of Foundation guards while
the researcher followed, rattling off vague
information about the ‘expedition’.
Guided by the armed escort into another room,
Javi was flocked by more Foundation staff,
strapping electronic equipment over the outside
of his orange prisoner garb.
One piece of it was to monitor his heart rate,
another was a portable camera to record his
surroundings,
although those were among the few details
that he was actually able to catch during
all the activity.
Javi couldn’t help noticing how nobody had
even mentioned just where he was meant to
be going on this expedition,
just that the Foundation wanted to keep a
close eye on him while he was there.
“You still haven’t told me exactly where
it is I’m meant to be going,” he finally
spoke up.
“Or how I’m getting there.”
“All in good time,” the head researcher
replied.
“So far, the only detail you need to be
aware of is this: it’s dangerous.
A particularly hostile environment.”
“So, like a warzone?”
Javi asked.
The researcher smiled, but to themselves,
as if there was something funny about the
question and the lack of understanding it
conveyed.
Javi’s attention was quickly turned to another
D Class, wearing a similar D Class uniform
to him.
The staff began prepping the second convict
in the same room, although without nearly
as much gear as they’d given Javi.
“I thought I was the only one going on this
trip,” he stated.
“Oh, don’t worry, that’s just the lure,”
the researcher explained, though it only raised
more questions.
“They won’t be accompanying you.”
It was then Javi was led out of the prep room,
and walked through the Foundation facility.
The place was a hive of activity, as well
as noise.
There were alien shrieks and wails, monstrous
sounds emanating from deep in the building,
muffled only slightly underneath thick layers
of concrete and heavy steel doors.
On top of that, there were
screams, too, distinctly
human sounds of pain and fear.
Javi tried to ignore it as he was instructed
to keep walking, feeling almost nostalgic
for the clank of metal bars back at his old
cell.
He had been anticipating being taken out of
the facility, towards maybe a helipad or runway
where an aircraft would be waiting to fly
him out to his undisclosed destination.
In fact, even a dock with a moored boat would
have been more within the realm of what he
was expected.
But instead, he was taken deeper and deeper
into the Foundation’s sprawling complex,
passing testing areas and containment levels,
through winding corridors until...
Javi was told to stop in front of a heavy
door that held a containment area beyond.
He couldn’t help noticing that the door
itself looked brand new like it had only just
been installed.
Meanwhile, the frame surrounding it had traces
of discoloring and damage, almost as if something
corrosive had melted away the previous door,
hence the replacement.
“This is it?”
Javi asked, confused but still trying to nudge
more information out of the Foundation staff.
“You want me to do an ‘expedition’ within
your own building?”
“Yes and no,” the head researcher replied,
still giving next to no useful details.
“Now, this is important.
Once you get to your destination, we need
you to figure out how to get back to us.
You do that, and you’ll have your freedom,
your daughter, your second chance.”
“Surely to get back I can just open up this
door again?”
the prisoner said.
That garnered a slight
chuckle from the researcher,
again seeming to find Javi’s lack of understanding
amusing.
“Oh, D-14164.
If only it was that simple.”
The door opened with a heaving, metallic creak,
and Javi was unceremoniously pushed inside
by the guards.
Staggering inside, catching himself before
he lost his balance and fell over,
he almost turned back to start slamming his
fists against the now-sealed entrance.
He would have, were it not for the sight of
something oozing out of the wall directly
in front of him.
Javi stepped closer to inspect in, but withdrew
his hand as he noticed thick, black droplets
leaking onto the floor.
The substance hissed as it made contact with
the ground, like it was burning through, corroding
whatever it came into contact with.
Keeping himself from touching it, Javi leaned
in to get a closer look…
and found the grotesque face of SCP-106 looking
back at him.
A spindly, decrepit hand reached out of the
gooey puddle and grabbed the orange material
of Javi’s jumpsuit,
pulling at the garment with enough strength
to tug his entire body forward.
In a blind panic, Javi tried to swipe the
Old Man’s rotting arm away, feeling an intense
burning,
almost like a chemical scalding his skin as
the same black ooze burned through his clothing
and started to singe his chest.
Another hand shot forward out of the puddle
on the wall, a clawed thumb puncturing Javi’s
side.
He screamed in pain as he felt the blistering
digit pierce into him,
while the rest of the fingers pulled him closer
still to the wall, using the hole in his side
like a handle.
The stench of his own burning flesh mixed
with the air of rotting decay that SCP-106
brought with it everywhere.
The decaying face of the Old Man peered through
the black slime on the wall,
its mouth locked in a sadistic, sinister grin
as Javi found himself pulled inside.
It almost felt like he had fallen asleep in
the bathtub,
and woken up gasping and spluttering, just
having narrowly avoided drowning.
Except now he was waking up in an entirely
different space, the transition there having
done little to dull the pain of his injuries.
Sitting up as he arrived in his new dark and
desolate surroundings, Javi gripped his side
and winced at the searing pain.
Then, the sudden smell of burning plastic
crawled up his nostrils and down the back
of his throat.
Most of the equipment the Foundation had strapped
onto him was melting;
the heart rate monitor and camera corroding,
covered in more of that black sludge.
Standing up, gritting his teeth through the
pain of his wounds, Javi quickly removed the
devices as carefully as he could.
He was far beyond caring about the Foundation’s
‘expedition’, right now, he just wanted
to get back out of… wherever the hell this
place was.
Checking over his shoulder, the slick, corrosive
puddle he’d been pulled through was already
gone.
At any rate, Javi didn’t particularly like
the idea of going back that way, so was relieved
– although he’d soon find out that relief
was perhaps misplaced.
He had barely a few moments to examine his
surroundings, not that there was much he could
see besides endless dark corridors…
and the withered figure of the Old Man.
It had reappeared, looking like it was far
off in the distance before, in a split second,
the gap between SCP-106 and Javi had closed.
The creature tilted its bald, skeletal head
as it looked at him, and he got a full, unobscured
glimpse at its sunken eyes and face locked
in a perpetual lipless grin.
The rotting, wrinkly flesh of the Old Man’s
body was oozing more and more of that dark,
disgusting mucus,
droplets of it landing on Javi’s clothing
and burning holes right through.
One hand still applying pressure to his side,
Javi turned and tried to run as far and fast
as his body was able.
If getting away was his sole objective, he
wanted out as quick as possible,
anything to get away from the nightmarish
creature he had now found himself trapped
with.
Running didn’t seem to work though.
He was sure he had made it at least a few
feet,
the Old Man was still standing behind him
but looked to be at more of a distance.
That was, until Javi noticed his legs; they
were running backwards.
Each step he had taken away from SCP-106 was
being reversed, rewound like on an old VHS
tape,
bringing him back closer and closer to the
creature’s clutches.
Its claws pushed painfully through Javi’s
back as it reversed time right back to the
point where he had turned to run away.
As the Old Man reached through him, more of
that burning, acidic pain starting eating
away at its captive D Class prey,
with Javi letting out a pained scream.
It wasn’t until several minutes in that
he realized something that hurt almost just
as bad:
SCP-106 could have killed him in an instant.
That much was clear.
But it hadn’t.
It had chosen not to.
Instead, it was torturing him, prolonging
the pain Javi was experiencing…
because it wanted him to suffer.
With all its strength, SCP-106 hurled him
several feet, until Javi’s burning, corroding
body collided with a hard surface, a wall,
with a loud crack.
The Old Man then manipulated the time within
his pocket dimension, causing Javi to fly
backward through the air,
back into the creature’s corrosive grip.
It allowed time to keep winding back, undoing
all the damage it had done so far.
As much as Javi was relieved to be rid of
the searing pain he was in, a sick worry deep
in the pit of his stomach told him that this
wasn’t an act of mercy;
the Old Man just wanted to make him suffer
all over again.
He lost track of how long it went on for,
SCP-106 taking sick glee in hurting his captive,
only to reverse the time within the pocket
dimension and do it all again.
Each time felt just like the first, made worse
by the fact that Javi never had a chance to
get used to the pain, to become numb to it.
Instead, every moment the torture started
was just like the first time, in fact, it
technically was.
Screaming in agony, Javi had no clue if he
had been there for hours, days, months, or
even years.
Had any time passed at all?
How many times had the Old Man done this to
him,
only to reverse time and do it all over again,
letting the pain begin anew?
Every few tries, the Old Man would release
Javi for a moment.
But once again, it was never done out of any
sense of mercy or kindness.
It was so it could hunt him.
Still, Javi ran every time, as far and fast
as he could, searching every corner of the
dark, desolate place for some kind of way
out.
A portal home, another of those corrosive
black puddles, a big door with ‘Exit’
written on it in big red letters.
But instead, all he found was SCP-106… or
rather, the Old Man found him.
It was hunting him again.
Javi had no idea how many times this made.
Panting, he slowed to a halt, trying to catch
his breath.
Reaching out in the dark, he put a hand against
a nearby hard surface, a wall… then felt
a crack under his hand.
Examining closer, although he could barely
see it, Javi could feel, with absolute certainty,
that the wall had been damaged, just a little.
It was the same one, the exact same wall he
had been thrown against, who knew how long
ago.
But the point was, it was still cracked from
where his body had hit it, even after the
Old Man had reversed time to hurt Javi over
and over again, the damage had stayed.
He had no way of knowing if it would work,
or how long it would take, but it might have
been a way out.
Desperately, Javi slammed his fist against
the wall, feeling pain shooting through his
fingers and up into his arm as it collided
with the solid surface.
Nothing changed.
Winding back the other arm, he hit it again.
Still nothing.
Javi could hear the Old Man shuffling closer
behind him, could sense his hands reaching
out closer to torture him again.
He let it happen, striking one last blow against
the wall before it finally reached him, and
the pain began once more,
only to be reversed so SCP-106 could do it
all again.
But now, he had a goal.
Each time the creature rewound time and undid
all the damage to its captive’s body,
Javi went looking for that same wall, feeling
across every surface until he reached it again.
The damage was still there, only a tiny crack
for now, but time – despite being under
the Old Man’s control in this pocket dimension
– was on Javi’s side.
Whenever he made it back to the wall, he started
to punch at it again, pounding one fist against
it after the other.
He didn’t relent, despite the pain it caused
him, he told himself it would be worth it
if it meant he made it out.
Even the times when the bones in his hands
broke, and he was flimsily striking at the
cracked wall with shattered fingers, he didn’t
stop.
It would be worth it.
It had to be, no matter how long it took.
He would gradually chip away at the wall,
more and more.
Every time SCP-106 would find Javi, and when
it did, it would hurt him.
The pain he’d put himself through trying
to break down the wall helped numb some of
the torture before the Old Man and reset
everything
again.
Then, the hunt began again, and Javi went
back to making his gradual dent in the wall.
The whole time, he remembered he was doing
it for Kali, for his freedom, and a fresh
start.
Until, eventually, it stopped.
Javi had no idea how many times he’d struck
the wall, but it had been enough to start
tunneling through it slightly, both hands
bloody and broken again.
But this time, the Old Man didn’t appear.
It had stopped.
Screaming in rage, Javi started throwing himself
at the indented wall, trying desperately to
chip away more,
completely unaware that SCP-106 had left him
alone in its pocket dimension.
Back in their facility, the Foundation had
lost contact with Javi’s recording devices
over three hours ago,
at which point they had initiated their Recall
Protocol,
injuring the D Class they had chosen as a
lure.
Sure enough, the Old Man had reappeared from
his pocket dimension, following the pained
screams to come and finish the lure off.
There was no sign of Javi, and with a sigh,
the head researcher simply noted down:
‘SCP-106 Pocket Dimension Escape Test.
Result: test inconclusive.’
I made it? I actually made it? I’m still alive,
by some miracle – or maybe by sheer luck – I made
it to the end of my sentence. Over three months
of the most horrific work I’ve ever had to do,
with no other alternative. But it’s paid off,
because any minute now, they’ll be coming into the
dorm to let me go. I can walk out of here with my
head up. I can’t wait to get out of these orange
overalls that I’ve had to live in since I arrived.
It seems like so much longer, in all honesty. The
only way I’ve been able to keep track of how
many days I’ve been stuck here is by putting
tally marks on the wall next to my dormitory
bed. A hundred, I’ve been a member of D-Class
personnel for the SCP Foundation for the last
one hundred days. And here’s how I survived…
They didn’t waste any time early on; I’ll give
the Foundation that. I’d barely been out of my
sentencing hearing for a few days. Put on trial
and convicted for a crime I didn’t even commit.
There had been a string of murders, and someone
who had either been involved or was responsible
laid the blame on me. But whoever they were, they
had powerful friends. The cops were in on it,
planting evidence to frame me and make it look
like I was guilty when I was really innocent.
That’s what landed me in prison, serving a
sentence of twenty-five years to life behind bars.
And it was during my first week of incarceration
that he showed up. The recruitment specialist,
a clean-cut, blunt, Agent Smith type came
to visit me. I hadn’t even been in prison
long enough to have visitor privileges, but
the shady agent seemed to know which strings
to pull in order to ask me an important question:
“What would you do to get out of here?” he’d said.
To which my answer was “Anything.”
That was my first mistake.
Immediately, the next day I received a letter
detailing more about what exactly Agent Smith
was offering. It was folded and hidden in the
spine of a book that a guard handed me during
reading hour. Unfolding the message, it all
felt like an old-school covert spy tactic.
“To Mr Emil Carker,” the letter read. “We
understand that you recently received a
criminal conviction. There are two options
currently before you, as detailed below. One:
you can serve out the remainder of your sentence
in prison. Or two: you can be released into the
care of our organization. While with us,
you will be helping to further scientific
advancements through hard work. We have devised
a system that allows convicts such as yourself to
perform a vital role within our organization, in
return for a reduction in their prison sentences.
“We have no interest in or intention of
determining any guilt for the crimes for
which you are currently convicted. We merely seek
to present this opportunity to you. We ask that
you destroy this letter once you have finished
reading. Should you be interested in our offer,
then please recite the phrase ‘it’s a yes’ to
a prison guard with the badge number: 47890.”
Naturally, as cryptic as an offer like that
was, I didn’t need much time to mull it over.
I was trapped in prison for something I
didn’t do, with no way to appeal for my
freedom or prove my innocence. So, taking up a
mysterious job opportunity from a shadowy group
seemed like a much better alternative at the
time. After all, I could either work off my
sentence through employment, or rot away in a
cell for the next two and half decades at minimum.
All I had to do next was find the right guard.
I tried not to make it obvious that I was eyeing
every prison guard’s badge number as they
stood around, keeping a close eye on me
and the other inmates. But it was while out
in the yard that I saw him: number 47890.
I had gone to bed with a knot in my stomach.
Hours earlier, I had done exactly as the
letter said and approached the guard, making
sure I was close enough for him to hear me,
but trying to make it clear that I wasn’t
looking tor start any trouble either.
“It’s a yes,” I told him.
In response, 47890 had furrowed his brow and
scrunched his mustache, seemingly in disgust.
“Back up, inmate,” he commanded sharply.
I backed away with my hands raised, confused as
to what had just happened. I spent the entire
rest of the day thinking about it; maybe the
note had been a prank, some kind of initiation,
seeing as I was the newest prisoner. But that
didn’t explain the agent who had shown up
before. What was going on? The questions that were
spinning around in my head eventually wore me out.
And while I slept, that’s when
someone put a bag over my head,
drugged me, and snuck me out of prison.
When I woke up, I was somewhere new, a room filled
with other convicts. Although not many of them
seemed to have come from the same prison I had
been sentenced to; plenty were sporting different
jumpsuits, but their gruff demeanors told me all
I needed to about them. I was surrounded by
a more violent breed of criminal, some of the
worst of the absolute worst. The atmosphere in
this pen full of murderers and monsters was so
tense that it felt like the slightest accidental
bump could explode into a full-blown fight.
Suddenly, a hatch in the ceiling opened, and a
pile of clothes came thumping down from above.
It was a mass of orange, enough matching overalls
for every inmate in the room. Of course, I held
back from the initial clamor some of the others
made, grabbing their new prison garb, snatching
orange overalls from each other, and arguing. When
I eventually got mine, I noticed an unfamiliar
logo emblazoned on the front of the uniform.
After being made to wait a whole day in the pen,
the other prisoners and I were filed out of
the room by heavily armed security guards.
We were all directed towards a hall, nobody
was daring enough to challenge the officers,
even the more violent among the prisoners.
I spotted that the guard’s uniforms bore the
same insignia as the overalls we’d been made to
wear. It must’ve been the logo of the mysterious
organization that had offered me employment.
We were given an orientation talk led by
someone who introduced themselves as a Junior
Assistant Researcher. They explained that our
current location was highly classified, as was
the true identity of the group that had arranged
for us to be released. All we were told was that
this was an unspecified form of research facility,
and that we had to cooperate with the facility’s
staff if we wanted to secure our release. It
seemed straightforward enough, although
the Junior Assistant Researcher seemed to
make a lot of jokes about us dying during
these tests. I think they hoped it would
alleviate some of the tension… it didn’t.
After sitting through the orientation talk,
I still had more questions than answers. The
one thing I had learned was that being tattooed
hurt. Exiting the hall, the other prisoners and
I had been directed to get a designation number
tattooed on our wrist and across our chest.
When someone had asked why the chest, the
Researcher conducting orientation had answered:
“Well, in the event of an explosion, it's most
likely that it'll be the largest intact chunk of
meat left.” This was another of their ‘jokes’.
Still feeling sore as my tattoo healed, I read
the number now permanently inked onto my body:
D-2152. ‘D-Class Personnel’ that’s what they
called us now. We were directed into a dormitory,
a lot less cramped than my old cell. But
still, being surrounded by violent criminals
when I knew I didn’t belong there, it
felt no less isolating. One of them,
who took the bunk next to mine, introduced himself
to me as ‘Shiv’. Worried he might try to kill me,
I did my best to be friendly towards him.
Shiv and I didn’t exactly bond, but more
sprung up conversations because there was little
else to do. I was still worried about some of the
flippant comments made about us all dying,
until he pointed out something far stranger.
“Don’t you wonder why they’re
making us wait?” he asked.
And the moment he mentioned it, I did start
to wonder about that. It seemed odd that this
organization had wasted little time
in getting us all here. It had only
been a week ago that I entered my prison
cell for the first time, now I was here.
“I think it’s their way of telling us,” Shiv
went on. “That we aren’t here to be helpful,
to be a workforce for them. They’ve
brought us all here to die.”
That comment made me look around, and actually
acknowledge the people I was trapped with. They
were some of the worst criminals imaginable,
irredeemable killers. Would this organization
really let those people back out into the
world after helping out with a few tests?
I’d soon find out, because Day 8
was the last day before I found
myself working directly for the SCP Foundation.
I picked up the name from a few places around the
facility; nametags, lab coats, and security
uniforms, always with the same logo. Me and
the other D-Class personnel were woken up early in
the morning by a bell and issued with assignments.
From the very first day the work started, I
noticed that not all the others came back to the
dorm at the end of the day. Shiv was one of those.
My tasks mostly consisted of cleaning up with a
mop, hosing down empty testing chambers that had
a worrying amount of blood sprayed over the walls
and floors. The regiments were strict, and I made
sure to do exactly what was asked of me to avoid
causing any trouble. It felt a lot like being back
in prison, but with the only added caveat of being
able to move around the facility, even if it
was to go and wipe up the Foundation’s mess.
Although the other classes of personnel didn’t
seem to take kindly to my help, making snide
comments as they passed me in the hallways. We had
been told not to address the other staff unless
spoken to, which was frustrating. I certainly
had a few things I would’ve liked to say to them.
After two and a half weeks without so much as a
hint of any trouble, I was given my first testing
assignment that wasn’t just cleaning up. You
would think that would be exciting, but having
seen some of the carnage left behind after other
tests, I was anything but eager to take part.
Luckily for me, and pretty surprisingly,
my first test was pretty straightforward.
I was shown to a room containing a
white bowl decorated with light blue
flowers that the researchers referred to
as SCP-348. I had received a nasty splinter
from my mop’s handle the day before, and was
instructed to sit down and eat from the bowl,
which was filled with soup. Naturally, I eagerly
ate it all, despite how bitter it tasted. It was
better than the food from the D-Class canteen at
least. But when I finished, I noticed a message
had appeared at the bottom of SCP-348. It read:
“I don’t believe you were framed. Goodbye, son.”
After that, it was as if the floodgates had
been opened, and every day I was asked to do
another test with a new SCP. Most were harmless
anomalous creatures or objects, like one of the
bigger experiments I was involved in, which
focused on SCP-999, this friendly gelatinous
orange blob. Electrodes were hooked up to me
while I just sat calmly in a room with SCP-999.
Being around it made me feel great, the best I had
felt since arriving and joining D-Class. Although
I did hear one of the researchers making the
comment that SCP-999 was ‘not quite ready yet’.
Even so, the Tickle Monster had given me a new
positive outlook on my role at the Foundation.
It was odd work, but I could find a rhythm to
it that would hopefully make the time pass by
a little quicker. And if it meant getting out, it
was worth all the dirty looks from other classes
of personnel. This was an outlook I didn’t want
to lose. After a month, we were told to take a
pill that the guards handed out to us, something
called an amnestic that would make us all forget
the previous month. But, wanting to hang on to my
newfound optimism, I secretly flushed mine down
a toilet. In hindsight, I should have taken it.
My next big test quickly brought me back down a
peg. I was handed a katana, SCP-572, and instantly
felt like I was unstoppable. The sword made me
believe I was a powerful warrior, as if I could
maybe fight my way out of the Foundation facility
with ease. Unfortunately, the moment I tried to
use it didn’t lead to freedom. I had an accident,
broke my arm and suffered a series of internal
fractures, all while the research team mocked me.
Embarrassed, I felt like a total laughing stock.
Things only got worse from there. I had barely
set foot outside of the infirmary before a
different team of personnel told me I was
going to be assisting them with an important
task. They dragged me to an old wooden door
after briefly explaining what was going on;
although I struggled to keep up. Beyond the
door – which they called SCP-2317 – was a
vast salt pan. Following their instructions,
I acted as an assistant to the rest of the team as
they performed a strange ritual. I had to scatter
a mix of holy water and chicken blood around
a circle of seven stone pillars, then recite:
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New King.”
It was an unusual practice, to say the least,
but apparently, I was helping keep a
powerful, vengeful demigod imprisoned.
That did little to soften the news that I
heard when we returned through SCP-2317.
While I was gone, one of the Foundation’s
security team had been infected by something
known as SCP-2193, a phenomenon that makes
people believe that every month a large group
of D-Class are to be ‘terminated’. When I heard,
I actually considered taking my amnestic for this
month to forget just how many had been killed…
It had been a whole two months since I had
actively started work as part of D-Class
Personnel, and there weren’t many of my
fellow prisoners left. I was sent for a mandatory
psychological evaluation; the Foundation wanted
to know if I would still be able to perform tests
for them. I doubted it came from a place of actual
concern, it’s not like they cared all that much
if the things I had seen were taking a toll on me.
Sitting across from the researcher performing my
evaluation, I did my best impression of a normal
person. I had to pretend like none of it was
getting to me, all the horrors and the close brush
I’d almost had with death by Monthly Termination.
I wouldn’t have lied about it normally, But I’d
been told I had a month left before I was due to
be released. Apparently, not many D-Class made it
that far, given the dangerous nature of testing.
All I could think about was how good it would
feel to eat real food again; I started to daydream
about getting a cheeseburger on my first day out.
Almost instantly, my hopes for freedom were
dashed the very next day. I was told I’d be
going on a longer assignment, this time it would
be an expedition into an anomalous location called
SCP-432. The Foundation’s researchers outfitted
me with a flashlight, plus extra batteries. A
headset and microphone linked to their control
center were placed over my ear, along with a
camera unit mounted on my shoulder; they said
it would wirelessly transmit back to them,
and they’d see what I saw. I was also given a
couple of bottles of water, some energy bars,
and a few sticks of luminous marker chalk.
But when they had said ‘anomalous location’,
the last thing I’d been expecting was
to climb into a rusty metal cabinet.
The next two weeks were like living inside a
nightmare. Inside the cabinet was a huge maze,
a literal labyrinth all made out of the same
rusted steel of the exterior of SCP-432. It was
so dark, even with the use of my flashlight and
the few lightbulbs affixed to some of the walls
within the Cabinet Maze. Before long, I ended
up losing my bearings, lost with no way out.
But being trapped in the maze and the
dark wasn’t even the worst parts. There
was something else in the labyrinth, some
kind of creature lurking through the metal
corridors. My flashlight eventually ran
out of power, so I never actually saw it,
but every time I tried to sleep, I’d just lay
awake, listening to its growls. I couldn’t help
what kind of horrible thing was out there, and
might be looming over me in the dark. Even when
I opened my eyes, I still wouldn’t get to see it.
Eventually, another D-Class was sent into SCP-432.
By some miracle, he was able to not only find
me, but guide me back to the entrance of the
Cabinet Maze. The moment I was free, I yelled at
the research team, demanding they let me go. I
didn’t just mean let out of SCP-432, I meant free
from D-Class, from the Foundation, from all of it.
I was sent for another psyche evaluation
and deemed to be fine, just suffering from
heightened stress. When they asked me if I’d been
taking my amnestics, I lied and told them yes.
Ten days before I was set to be released and they
couldn’t help but assign me to one last test.
“Don’t worry,” a researcher sarcastically assured
me. “This one will be nice and easy on you,
you’ll just have to jump into a paddling
pool. You can do that, can’t you, D-2152?”
The paddling pool in question was SCP-120.
Every time a different glow emanated from it,
I was instructed to jump in. The exact second I
did, I found myself transported somewhere new.
I got The Himalayas on my first go, Greenland
and the Sahara Desert on the next two tries.
Every one of the locations I ended up
at had some kind of Foundation facility
established nearby. They’d pick me up, and I’d
be taken back to SCP-120 to continue testing.
It felt like I was being deliberately,
intentionally tortured. The Foundation
was giving me these momentary glimpses
of freedom every time I was teleported by
SCP-120. It was a carrot on the end of a stick
that they were keeping just out of my reach,
and I hated it. It made me realize that
I had never been there to work for them,
being part of D-Class Personnel wasn’t a
job. All I was to them was a human lab rat.
Now it’s my last day. They’ve promised me that by
the end of today, I won’t be here anymore. I just
want to be out, done with D-Class for good. The
Foundation’s researchers have given me one last,
simple test to do before I go. They said if I
do, then I’ll be gone. All they want me to do
is wear this amulet for someone called Doctor
Bright. How hard can that be? And they said
they’d let me go after this one last thing, so
it can’t be anything all that bad, right? Right…?